welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford School of Medicine
today my guest is Dr Rina Malik Dr Rina
Malik is a board-certified urologist and
pelvic surgeon she is an expert in both
male and female Urological pelvic floor
and sexual health during today's episode
Dr Malik answers the most commonly asked
questions about urinary pelvic and
sexual health for instance how to avoid
getting UTI's urinary tract infections
we also discuss pelvic floor anatomy and
function as it relates to overcoming an
overly tight or an overly relaxed pelvic
floor this is a key distinction that
most people aren't aware of many people
hear about the need to so-called
strengthen their pelvic floor but in
fact many people need to do the exact
opposite they need to learn to relax
their pelvic floor in order to achieve
proper Urologic and sexual function
so today you'll learn about that you
will also learn about sexual health as
it relates to erectile function as it
relates to things like vaginal
lubrication as it relates to orgasm we
separate out very carefully the
difference between psychological desire
an arousal that occurs within the
genitals themselves and Dr Malik
highlights some important misconceptions
about sexual dysfunction for instance
that many people believe that hormones
are responsible for sexual dysfunction
but in reality
hormone dysregulation is responsible for
only a very small percentage of sexual
dysfunction and yet
pelvic floor and blood flow related
issues can account for a large number of
cases of sexual dysfunction in both
males and females so I assure you that
today's discussion is going to
illuminate many new areas of information
many new tools and protocols that I'm
guessing most people have not heard of
we talk about the neural vascular that
is blood flow related and muscular
aspects of bladder function prostate
functions schemes glands we talk about
vaginal Health as well as penile Health
we talk about these things as it relates
to different stages across the lifespan
it is a far-reaching and in-depth and
practical conversation that I'm certain
everyone will glean important takeaways
from now before we go any further I do
want to highlight that the content of
today's episode is sexual in nature we
talk very directly about different types
of sexual behavior and we talk about it
from the standpoint of the clinician and
biologist so it is a medical slash
scientific discussion that said we can't
be aware of where this podcast is being
played and who is listening and I assert
that there are certain themes within
today's discussion that would not be
suitable for young children how young
well that is certainly not for us to
discern we realize that different
parents and different households should
be the Arbiters of what sorts of
information their children are exposed
to or not so my suggestion would be that
if you have any concern whatsoever that
the content of today's episode would not
be appropriate to be heard by some
member of your family that you please
listen to the podcast first or at least
check the time stamps where we've
detailed what specific topics are
covered and then to make your decision
accordingly I should mention that not
only is Dr Malik still an active
clinician she sees patients daily out of
her clinic in Southern California and we
provided a link to that clinic in the
show note captions she's also authored
dozens of high quality peer-reviewed
Publications in the fields of Urology
pelvic health and sexual will health and
we've also provided a link to that
bibliography in the show note captions
and she is also a spectacular public
educator she provides zero cost content
about sexual health pelvic floor health
and Urology as it relates to both men
and women on her YouTube channel and
there too we've provided a link to Dr
Malik's YouTube channel in the show note
captions to this episode before we begin
I'd like to emphasize that this podcast
is separate from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford it is however
part of my desire and effort to bring
zero cost to Consumer information about
science and science related tools to the
general public in keeping with that
theme I'd like to thank the sponsors of
today's podcast our first sponsor is
Roca Roca makes eyeglasses and
sunglasses that are the absolute highest
quality
I've spent a lifetime working on the
biology of the visual system and I can
tell you that your visual system has to
contend with an enormous number of
challenges in order for you to be able
to see clearly Roca understands this and
has developed their eyeglasses and
sunglasses so that you always see with
perfect clarity in addition they are
extremely lightweight and they won't
slip off your face if you get sweaty
indeed Roca eyeglasses and sunglasses
were initially designed for performance
in sports but now they include
Aesthetics and styles that are really
designed to be worn anytime I for
instance wear readers at night I'll
sometimes wear sunglasses during the day
when I drive and of course I do not wear
sunglasses when I do my morning sunlight
viewing which I highly recommend
everyone do their morning sunlight
viewing if you'd like to try Roca
eyeglasses or sunglasses you can go to
Roka that's roka.com and enter the code
huberman to save 20 off your first order
again that's Roca roka.com enter the
code huberman at checkout
today's episode is also brought To Us by
Helix sleep Helix sleep makes mattresses
and pillows that are customized to your
unique sleep needs in order to allow you
to get the best possible night's sleep
sleep is the foundation of mental health
physical health and performance when we
are sleeping well and enough mental
health physical health and performance
all stand to be at their best one of the
key things to getting a great night's
sleep is to make sure that your mattress
is tailored to your unique sleep needs
Helix sleep has a brief two minute quiz
that if you go to their website you take
that quiz and answer questions such as
do you tend to sleep on your back your
side or your stomach do you tend to run
hot or cold in the middle of the night
maybe you don't know the answers to
those questions and that's fine at the
end of that two minute quiz they will
match you to a mattress that's ideal for
your sleep needs I sleep on the dusk at
the usk mattress and when I started
sleeping on a dust mattress about two
years ago my sleep immediately improved
so if you're interested in upgrading
your mattress go to helixsleep.com
huberman take their two-minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress for you and you'll
get up to 350 off any mattress order and
two free pillows again if interested go
to helixsleep.com huberman for up to 350
off and two free pillows we are always
dry driving to make the huberman Lab
podcast better and to that end we need
your help over the next month we are
going to be carrying out a survey the
purpose of the survey is to improve the
huberman Lab podcast according to your
feedback we put together a brief survey
to understand what you love about the
podcast hopefully you love a few things
at least or maybe just one thing as well
as what you think could be improved or
perhaps the many things that you think
could be improved about the huberman Lab
podcast basically what we are asking is
to get your feedback so that we can
improve any and all things about the
huberman Lab podcast the survey does not
take long and every single response will
be reviewed as a thank you for
completing the survey we are offering
two months free of the huberman lab
premium channel if you're already a
member of the huberman lab premium
channel do not worry you will get an
additional two free months for carrying
out this survey you can find the link to
the survey in the show notes for this
podcast episode and on our website
hubermanlab.com so if you would be so
kind as to take a few minutes to fill
out the survey and help us continue with
bringing you the best possible content
here at The huberman Lab podcast and as
always thank you for your interest in
science and now for my discussion with
Dr Rina Malik Dr Rina Malik welcome
thank you thank you so much it's an
honor to be here I'm delighted to have
you here I'm a huge fan of your content
I find that you are able to deliver
critical information about sexual health
Urology pelvic floor
libido and so many other things that are
of immense interest to people but that
ordinarily people don't really know
where to get the high quality
information and coming to you for that
information means they are going to get
the highest quality information I truly
believe that because
as everyone will soon hear today we're
going to have a very Frank discussion
but one that's really grounded in
science and medicine
around sexual health and related topics
these are topics that typically people
learn about
perhaps a little bit in school maybe at
home
from Friends
usually overhearing things as opposed to
direct exploratory conversation
online
pornography
and at least in my experience growing up
you know there was education around
Sexual Health reproductive Health Etc
that was more oriented toward the fear
of
things like STIs fear of unwanted
pregnancy all of which of course is
extremely important for people to learn
about but far less about sort of the
healthy versions of sexual health right
yeah absolutely so this is an especially
important conversation
uh it's also one that I think
has a backdrop that we should just
acknowledge right off the bat that
because the information is gleaned from
multiple sources and because there are
um let's just say uh influences out
there that relate to the morality of
different practices that there can be
shame
there can be misunderstanding there can
be secrecy and that further leads to
misinformation so I'm confident that
today you can clarify things for us and
we're going to stay out of those
trenches and the last thing I'd like to
say is that because a number of terms
will certainly come up and I think for
some people they're not used to hearing
and general discourse I'm just going to
get them out of the way now penis vagina
anus prostate you know what else is
there we're going to talk about libido
we're going to talk about intercourse
oral sex anal sex we're going to talk
about all of that so I just want to get
that out there so that um we can reduce
the shock uh the shock response I love
it we got to talk about all of it great
so to start things off in anticipation
of this episode I solicited for
questions on social media and I got
thousands of questions but there was a
lot of overlap in the questions
so
to start off I'd like to talk about
pelvic floor okay because both males and
females have a pelvic floor
and my understanding is that there's a
muscular component there's a neural
muscular component there's a blood flow
component
what is a healthy pelvic floor what does
a healthy pelvic floor do and then we
can talk about some of the health issues
that an unhealthy pelvic floor creates
and some of the ways to ameliorate an
unhealthy pelvic floor absolutely so
pelvic floor very simply is basically a
bowl of muscles that's connected to
bones that hold up all your organs so
basically in your pelvis there's all
these muscles there and their function
is essentially many it helps with
urination defecation sexual function it
helps with posture and so having a
strong healthy pelvic floor can mean
that you're having normal urination
you're having normal defecation you're
having great sex and that you are also
not having ailments like back pain or
issues related to those those functions
and those organs
and so you know pelvic floor is is so
important in so many different aspects
and we deal with it a lot as urologists
because it's so integral to these
functions that we take care of and so
when you have an unhealthy pelvic floor
it can vary from person to person and
while you hear about it a lot in women
men also suffer from pelvic floor
dysfunction or problems with the pelvic
floor so basically pelvic floor
dysfunction happens a lot when you're
doing things like if you were to go to
the gym and do repetitions of of any
sort of exercise and you didn't rest
then that muscle would become contracted
and short very similarly if your pelvic
floor is over strained it can become
contracted and short and tight all the
time and you may not know it it may just
be a function of stress anxiety or
overuse or posture problems things of
that nature that can affect your pelvic
floor and so this can lead to issues
let's start with urination you can have
symptoms of urgency frequency meaning
you have to go a lot to the bathroom or
you have to go and have a sudden desire
that you can't delay sometimes even have
leakage in some cases it can make it
difficult to urinate because the pelvic
floor is so tense or perhaps to
incompletely vacate the bladder correct
like you go to urinate and then you go
back to your desk or then five minutes
later you have to urinate again exactly
something of that well it can be either
that you're not emptying completely or
that the pelvic floor muscles are so
tense that they're stimulating the
bladder so it feels like there's more to
go so it's not always that you're not
evacuating it can present in a number of
different ways
and then with uh with sexual function it
if it's very tense you can have pain so
you can have pain with sex you can have
pain with erections you can have pain
with ejaculation sometimes it can be a
lot of different kind of pain syndromes
and you're like I have all these
different things going on and it's
really just pelvic floor dysfunction
um with with GI function you can
definitely have constipation and then
often you can also have back pain and so
all of these things can happen when your
pelvic floor is too tense sometimes your
pelvic floor can be too weak and that
can be often because of we see this in
women a lot because of childbirth
delivering children with some people who
have neurologic disorders they can have
weak pelvic floors or connective tissue
disorders like there's download syndrome
for example these sorts of things can
cause weakness to the pelvic floor which
can then cause very often what I see is
like urinary incontinence or leakage
which can then you know create problems
for people down the line
thank you for that so first question how
does somebody know if their pelvic floor
is too tight from a over contraction or
chronic contraction of the muscles there
versus too weak and one of the
challenges in having this conversation
is that if we were talking about
contraction of the calf muscle or the
bicep I think everyone intuitively knows
because they've seen the shortening of
the muscles when the muscle is quote
unquote flexed and the lengthening of
the muscles when it is relaxed
um is there a way to describe pelvic
floor muscular shortening in a way that
everyone can understand would this be
like
um like I said we're going to be direct
today would this like be like tensing up
one's um uh
anus and the opposite of of the movement
that one would do before initiating a
bowel movement and relaxation is sort of
the pattern of pelvic floor muscular
relaxation just prior
to initiating a bowel movement so I will
say most people can't recognize it
because it's very difficult to notice
it's sort of uh gradual and so it can
over time become noticeable with these
symptoms but otherwise it's very
difficult because it's not a muscle that
we were ever trained to recognize right
like you hear about Kegel exercises for
example and people talk about how to do
them but that's all you ever hear about
the pelvic floor and so you don't really
know how to kind of do things in a way
that protects your pelvic floor or um or
kind of what how to even tell when it's
too tight or not relaxing and so that
takes a sort of a training and so
usually when people come to First you
get an examination to see if your pelvic
floor is tight so for women it's a
pelvic exam and for men it's usually a
rectal exam how does how does that exam
go so you know it's essentially
palpating the muscles and also looking
at the function so we'll say for digital
palpation where that's a medical
technology for fingers they're called
digits uh so
um you know I'm old enough to uh to
recognize what a digital prostate exam
is right the physician inserts their
fingers through it into the anus and and
and feels the prostate to see whether or
not it's swollen or not and and as I'm
saying this I'm realizing you know
sometimes we think of medicine quote
unquote modern medicine is so evolved
this is basically basically been the
practice for what 50 years 60 years
maybe 100 years in the same way that the
the old school practice for glaucoma
excessive eye pressure was for the
physician to just touch the eyeball so
uh folks for those of you that think
that medicine has evolved much uh it
clearly has in many ways but
um in any event so a prostate exam goes
as I just described what would a what
would a pelvic floor exam for a male and
a pelvic floor exam for a female
um involved at a kind of granular level
yeah so for for women you can feel the
pelvic floor muscles through the vagina
so you can feel the iliococcygeus the
pubic oxygous the levator Ani those are
all names of different muscles in this
bowl this is the physician who can feel
them with their fingers correct and you
know you could too you could put your
finger in but you don't have a reference
of normal right so you wouldn't know
what a normal pelvic floor feels like
versus a tight one versus a weak one and
so you can assess the tenseness based on
you know palpation you can also see if
there's tenderness and so you can assess
that based on just a general physical
examination and then also you can
observe so I can say contract your
squeeze your pelvic floor up and then I
can look and see are they squeezing or
are they pushing like are they
coordinated or not right because that's
a function of normal use of the pelvic
floor and sometimes you'll see that
they're just coordinated you can also
assess for sensation in the area and
things like that that could be
consequences of dysfunction can there be
dysfunction in laterality like the
pelvic floor is pulling up and to the
right or up and to the left absolutely
so what typically when you see a pelvic
floor therapist now I'm not a pelvic
floor therapist but these are the people
who will do the work right they they
work with you on a prolonged basis to
help you normalize the function of your
pelvic floor it's like going to the gym
with a trainer right they really work
with you to get your pelvic floor
functioning correctly and the first step
to that a lot of pelvic floor therapists
will just align your bones and and your
your kind of the way you sit and walk to
make sure that you're not straining
those muscles by pulling in different in
different directions and if a male goes
to the physician to get a pelvic floor
exam
um there's obviously
difficulty in putting fingers into the
urethra one would hope too small an
opening so how are they doing the pelvic
floor exam is it external to the body or
is it through the anus so some of it's
through the anus you can feel the
muscles through the at least and then
you can feel the perineal area and feel
the muscles there as well as Sensations
so okay so perineal area so from the
outside of the body okay
um the region between the scrotum and
the anus yes okay so it sounds to me
like if people want to get
a high quality assessment of whether or
not their pelvic floor is healthy or not
they need to see a pelvic floor
specialist that it's not the sort of
thing that they could into on their own
necessarily it would be difficult I mean
so there are things you can buy online
like probes that you can insert in the
vagina that will teach you how to do
kegel exercises and give you some read
you know some readings but they're not
really meant to diagnose they're usually
something people use if they they have a
weak pelvic floor and they want to try
to do it at home on their own so there's
nothing that's going to give you like a
baseline reading is this normal or
abnormal let's talk about kegels
um first of all who's Kegel
so he is a a gynecologist I don't
remember all the specifics to be quite
honest but basically he came up with
kegels which are a strengthening
exercise for the pelvic floor and so
what it is what we describe it to for
patients is we say you're going to
there's a few different ways to describe
it you're going to use the muscles that
you use when you urinate but try to stop
the flow but you don't want to do them
when you're urinating because that can
create dysfunction you want to learn
what the muscles are and then you
squeeze those muscles and relax you know
in between sets so to speak and so
you'll do the other way people describe
it is pulling up and in in the like the
vagina or for men sometimes you'll say
it's like the feeling that you're trying
to lift your penis off the floor without
touching it right so those are kind of
used the way you describe it yeah yeah
so those are kind of the ways that you
can describe those muscles and so you
can squeeze for five seconds and relax
for five seconds and do them in
repetitions and they're just like any
sort of exercise you do you don't want
to start doing a hundred of them right
you want to do them I tell them people I
tell patients do them lying down so that
you're only focusing on those muscles
you're not working on your posture
you're not doing anything else and as
you get better with them lying down you
then sit up and do them and then once
you're good with them sitting up you can
do them standing and start with you know
10 to 15 at a time like 15 repetitions
yeah
so yeah 10 to 15 repetitions in the
morning 10 to 15 repetitions at night
maybe one more during the middle of the
day but don't overdo it because just
like anything especially when you're
starting out you can and if you're doing
tons and tons of kegels then you will
get a tight short pelvic floor muscles
and you will then develop pelvic floor
dysfunction so it's really important to
kind of understand those mechanics which
is why a lot of people think they know
how to do kegels but they really don't
and so I always encourage people if you
have the time and the resources to go to
a pelvic floor physical therapist so
they can really work with you and make
sure you're doing them correctly
what are some of the benefits of kegels
for those that need them yes so they are
typically prescribed for urinary
incontinence specifically stress urinary
incontinence so leakage that occurs when
you have an increase in your
intra-abdominal pressure like a valsalva
or coughing sneezing lifting heavy
things jumping on a trampoline so for
those purposes we use kegels to
strengthen the pelvic floor and also in
women pelvic organ prolapse so when you
have weakness of the pelvic floor that
leads to a bulge that you can visibly
see or feel in the vagina for men we
often prescribe them for people who have
had a prostatectomy who then
subsequently develop leakage after the
prostatectomy that is again stress
urinary incontinence now a lot of people
use kegels recreationally because
improving the pelvic floor musculature
can lead to more intense pelvic floor
contractions during orgasm which can be
more pleasurable and so some people do
it for those purposes but again I
caution people not to overdo it because
then you can lead to a more tense pelvic
floor which is not where we want to end
up yes I will underscore that cautionary
note
years ago I heard about kegels I was
like okay I'll try it sounds all good
right I only heard good things about
kegels
um and what it quickly resulted in was
painful urination
and I thought this is weird everyone's
saying kegels are so great
um and the best thing I could do for my
pelvic floor it seemed was to avoid
kegels yes
um and a little bit later when we're
talking about prostate I'll I'll explain
um at least what my experience was as it
relates to the prostate but I guess the
take-home message that I'm gathering
from what you're telling us is that
strengthening the pelvic floor is great
if you have a weak pelvic floor
strengthening your pelvic floor further
if you have a strong pelvic floor can be
detrimental it can be it can be if you
over train it just like if you over
train anything else and so
um you just have to if you really want
to do kegels if you have any symptoms at
all like you described painful urination
or the things I've described like pain
with erections pain with ejaculation
pain difficulty emptying any of those
symptoms stop and go see a urologist so
that they can kind of assess your pelvic
floor
what is the anti-kegal in other words if
somebody decides that they have a tight
pelvic floor how can they learn to relax
their pelvic floor so there's a lot of
different sort of things that you can do
so for women you can do massage of the
area you can use vaginal dilators to
help relax the muscles you can take
suppositories that have medications like
valium or baclofen which are muscle
relaxants and that can help as well
although they're not treatments they're
more of a Band-Aid but they can help
with the symptoms that you're having and
then you can also I think the best thing
is to work with a physical therapist
because they can teach you certain
exercises that will help down train the
pelvic floor for example one of the ones
I tell my patients is like happy baby
pose it actually you know stretches and
elongates the pelvic floor muscles so
doing these exercises regularly will
help you lengthen the pelvic floor
muscles
one thing that I've experienced extreme
pain from
and that stopping was one of the best
things that ever happened for my pelvic
floor was to not do any kind of
crunching movement with my legs crossed
I would go with these yoga classes at
one point in my life and I they'd have
everybody do these crunches and I've
always done some abdominal work here and
there during the week if I'm being
diligent but they would have us cross
our feet and that seemed to lead to some
pelvic floor discomfort that was similar
to what I had experienced when I did the
kegels yeah so again for me ceasing the
kegels was one of the best decisions I
ever made I only did them for a short
while I was like okay this is clearly
not for me and I guess that's another
point that tell me if you agree uh or
not that if you hear about something
online or on this podcast or anywhere
else and you try it and it seems to be
sending things in the wrong direction
either you're doing it wrong or it might
not be the right thing for you exactly
you know I think all too often we hear
this thing is great and people jump on
that bandwagon and then they end up
worsening their problems or developing
problems where they didn't have them
previously but
is there anything about the anatomy of
the neuromuscular connections or or
vasculature of the pelvic floor that
would provide support for my experience
there yeah that doing crunches with legs
crossed is essentially
um is it possible that's creating
asymmetries in the pelvic floor
um and now I'm sure I'm angering yoga
teachers and um crunch crunchinistas
everywhere but you know hey
um if it's a question of your pelvic
floor or a few extra delineations in
your abs you know where my vote's going
yeah so there's a couple things here
that we should dive into one is that
people don't often breathe correctly
during exercise right and so
diaphragmatic breathing is is really
important which is like a deep breath
that expands the diaphragm not kind of
shallow breathing that's just in your
mouth and throat and that is actually
when you you know when you do any sort
of exercise the your trainer will tell
you exhale on the effort right and
there's a reason for that because when
you inhale your pelvic floor relaxes
when you exhale your pelvic floor
contracts and and so it actually that
contraction stabilizes the pelvic floor
so whatever intra-abdominal pressure
you're you're causing to increase from
the exercise whether it's a squat or a
crunch or whatever you're increasing
your abdominal pressure your pelvic
floor is then Contracting to help
stabilize that and so part part of the
reason people tend to hold their breath
during crunches right they don't do the
appropriate breathing and so that can be
part of it
the other thing that can happen with
certain things is that there are you
know nerves and arteries particularly
the pudendal nerve and the pudential
artery that run through the pelvic floor
so when you get pelvic floor dysfunction
you can cause decreased blood flow to
the to the pelvic floor muscles which
can affect sexual function and you can
get nerve inflammation as well that can
also cause pain and so this is kind of
how it all comes together I'm so glad
that you mentioned blood flow I think
our entire discussion today should be
framed up at least in the back of our
minds and the minds of our listeners and
viewers as involving at least three
things you know anytime we're talking
about erectile function or dysfunction
or pelvic floor function or dysfunction
or vaginal lubrication or lack thereof
we need to think about the hormonal
influences
the blood flow related influences and
the neural influences including the
neural influences that come from the
brain the signals of arousal for
instance or lack of arousal um and so on
so we won't be overly systematic in in
our parsing of all this but I I think
what you just mentioned raises a really
important point that sometimes in an
effort to do something that's good for
the muscles like strengthen the muscles
one will cut off blood flow in fact one
of the more common questions I got and I
consulted with a couple of exercise
physiologists about this and they
confirmed that a lot of people who Squat
and deadlift heavy in the gym
or even who just tense their pelvic
floor when they're doing things like
dumbbell curls or other exercises
and especially people who seem to do a
lot of abdominal work
reported to me in the questions that
they experienced things like erectile
dysfunction
that they experience things like pain
during vaginal intercourse
that essentially they had created some
sort of what sounds to me like a hyper
contraction of the muscles in that area
that were impeding all the things that
they wanted as either side effects or
Direct effects of exercise because many
people are exercising for aesthetic
reasons and health reasons but nowadays
it seems especially on the male side but
we'll also talk about the role of
testosterone on the female side a lot of
males lift weights in order to increase
their testosterone and for reasons that
are obvious also want to have healthy
sexual function and here they are doing
this thing that's very good for
increasing testosterone if they're doing
it correctly and testosterone is
involved in libido and the male sexual
response and the female sexual response
of course
but they are impeding their erections so
you can start to see how um there are
probably a lot of confused and maybe
even distraught people out there they're
trying to do all the right things and
they're setting up roadblocks and even
um sending themselves backward in some
cases so the question is
how does one know whether or not
something like
um let's say low lubrication or pain
during vaginal intercourse or loss of
erectile strength or some sort of
erectile dysfunction whatever it may be
because it can take on different forms
as we'll talk about how does one know if
it's blood flow related hormone related
or neural related and if it's neural
related how does one know if it's an
issue of lack of appropriate signals
from the brain over suppression or lack
of arousal from the brain or whether or
not it's some peripheral neural thing of
innervation of the penis or vagina so I
think there's there's a lot that we can
go into here but essentially first you
want to find out like very specifically
what is going on are you getting aroused
are you having erections are you
masturbating like there's all these
questions that will help us go down the
road sorry to interrupt when you say
aroused um for sake of this discussion I
just want to make sure that we
distinguish between psychological
arousal the desire to to
um I guess here we also have to be
precise
um arousal to engage in Intercourse and
arousal to
um desire essentially I think people
learn to recognize or are we talking
about arousal as the response of the
genitals correct so so desire and
arousal this is a very important concept
doesn't always go in One Direction
sometimes you can feel arousal meaning
you have the telltale signs of arousal
your nipples get erect you have more
lubrication if you're a female you're
both male and female nipples get erect
during around I believe so I think so
um you know you maybe get the second
flush right you get some some redness or
warmth feeling that's your body's
response right to arousal and sometimes
that can be an erection and sometimes
that's not not having an erection does
not mean you're not aroused it may mean
other things but certainly that's part
of it and then desire do you want to
have sex do you have like when you think
about your partner or you whoever you
want to engage with does is there a
desire to actually do that right or is
it just more of obligation or other
things and does it is that it doesn't
matter if the desire comes after arousal
for some women in particular we see that
they may not have the desire right away
but they want to be intimate or close
with their partner and so they'll start
just being close with them and then
arousal will come and then oh yeah you
know I like this so then the desire
comes after and that's normal that's
totally fine so you want to kind of
parse that out and then for men you can
ask are you getting erections at night
because that will tell us the function
of your organ at night very versus
during the day where you have also
psychogenic components right you can
really get in your head about erections
when you have a problem in the bedroom
with performance it becomes a vicious
cycle right so you you have a problem
the next time you're really stressed
you're not present you're not mindful in
the moment with sex and you're thinking
about oh my God am I going to perform
okay am I going to perform okay and then
it doesn't perform again and you're just
it's getting worse and worse and the
anxiety is through the roof and that's
actually causing your sexual dysfunction
so I think it's it's important first to
identify those issues and then also for
blood flow a lot of times we can we can
assess based on well what other
comorbidities do you have do you have
other issues ongoing that may be
affecting your blood flow most common
high blood pressure diabetes heart
disease and if you smoke all of those
things will affect blood flow to the
genitals and so that will Point
negatively negatively negatively so so
that will point us to a more vascular
issue hormonal issues are very important
for desire and and you know as far as
sexual function in terms of erections
there's only three percent of erectile
dysfunction that's related to hormones
so it's actually pure erectile function
correct as opposed to desire correct the
desire is desire is predominantly
modulated by the hormone testosterone
for both men and women in fact if you a
lot of people don't know this but women
have more testosterone in their bodies
and they actually have estrogen so
testosterone is very important for both
men and women for a variety of reasons
and so you you know using that
discussion with the patient will help
you kind of identify where you're headed
in terms of what you need to focus on
for treatment there are you know certain
things you can use to assess blood flow
you can do Doppler ultrasounds of the
penis as well as the clitoris to see if
there is good blood flow you can assess
the peak systolic velocity which will
tell you if the there's a problem with
arterial inflow versus the end diastolic
velocity which will tell you if there's
a problem with venous outflow and so
that can assess those things there are
some tests you can do for nerve
functionality they're very uncommonly
done because mostly we can kind of get
that through a clinical report and
unfortunately if you're having nerve
problems sometimes it depends on what's
causing them but sometimes they can be
very difficult to reverse and that's
kind of a problem we know that as people
age their sensation becomes less so just
through aging the nerves The receptors
become less sensitive and so you will
generally have less
responsiveness to the same Sensations
you did when you were younger and so
that kind of overlays all of this so
it's complex but really you know a lot
of it comes from the discussion you have
with your patient or you know you kind
of really doing a deep dive in what's
going on like really thinking about each
of those aspects and also what's going
on in your relationship and what's going
on in you know your life stress anxiety
like how are those playing around
as many of you know I've been taking ag1
daily since 2012. so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring the podcast ag1 is a
vitamin mineral probiotic drink that's
designed to meet all of your
foundational nutrition needs now of
course I try to get enough servings of
vitamins and minerals through whole food
sources that include vegetables and
fruits every day but oftentimes I simply
can't get enough servings but with ag1
I'm sure to get enough vitamins and
minerals and the probiotics that I need
and it also contains adaptogens to help
buffer stress simply put I always feel
better when I take ag1 I have more focus
and energy and I sleep better and it
also happens to taste great for all
these reasons whenever I'm asked if you
could take Just One supplement what
would it be I answer ag1 if you'd like
to try ag1 go to drinkag1.com huberman
to claim a special offer they'll give
you five free travel packs plus a year
supply of vitamin D3 K2 again that's
drink ag1.com huberman gosh Lots there
to unpack and I'm glad you mentioned the
relationship itself because there are
all sorts of things that can impact the
arousal response novelty not everyone's
in a committed relationship whether or
not people are engaging in a lot of
masturbation to the point of ejaculation
or climax or not pornography
Etc we will get into that it's a vast
space to explore before we go any
further I want to make sure however
that we cue people to where and how they
could find a really good let's say
pelvic floor
therapist
um and where they could find a really
great urologist to do the sorts of exams
and perhaps the sorts of treatments that
we've talked about because
um at least as far as I understand much
of what people want to learn on this
podcast is how things work and what
happens when things break down but also
how to resolve those issues so let's say
somebody wants to
um check out their pelvic floor figure
out what's going on there maybe they're
having issues maybe they're not if they
are male or female where do they go is
there a place online that has a great
list of some of the best ones in one's
area can it be done over telemedicine
um yeah how does one go about that yeah
so in terms of your pelvic floor it's
good to get assessed by a physician who
specializes in pelvic floor now if that
could be a urologist that could be a
gynecologist or even a Physical Medicine
Rehabilitation doctor that specializes
in pelvic floor health so typically
you'll see in urology you'll look for
people who are board certified in female
pelvic medicine and reconstructive
surgery if you're a woman if you're a
man maybe sexual medicine someone who
specializes in sexual medicine would be
a good place to look for a gynecologist
again you want to look at someone who
has interest in this area who you know
does manage pelvic floor and then in
terms of pelvic floor Physical Medicine
Rehabilitation at least when I was in
training there was about 20 PMR doctors
around the country who really focused on
this so it's not a lot of people if you
can go to a pelvic floor physical
therapist and you have one near you
that's great as well you um you do want
to make sure that when they do are
certified in pelvic floor physical
therapy and that they have taken care of
your gender so if you have male anatomy
then you want to go to someone who's
actually seen men because a lot of the
pelvic floor physical therapists tend to
treat a lot of women and so that's kind
of what I tell my patients generally
speaking there's no at least to my
knowledge no great resource and maybe
we'll we'll look that up and see if we
can find one that's very helpful thank
you and because again going back to what
I said at the beginning of our
conversation I think there's a lot of
you know shame or at least a lack of
clarity as to how one gets help for
issues that uh relate to the genitals
right because if you have a headache or
you're having an eye issue I mean you
sort of know where to go yeah hopefully
your headache doesn't weren't going to a
neurologist but it might
um you know eye stuff tends to be
ophthalmologist optometrists right yeah
um so I don't think we hear often enough
about where to access the best quality
care for these things so thank you for
that in thinking about sexual
dysfunction I'd like to have that
conversation more or less in parallel if
we can around male sexual dysfunction
and female sexual dysfunction and I want
to make sure that before we do that that
I'm creating the correct parallel
construction as they say
erectile dysfunction in males is clearly
a form of sexual dysfunction
what is the parallel to erectile
dysfunction in females is it lack of
vaginal lubrication and lack of
relaxation of the vagina to have
non-painful intercourse I mean is there
is it even possible to have a parallel
conversation about these two things so
it's different
different in in some circum
homologue of the clitoris right so the
clitoris is the I you know essentially
the same sort of spongy erectile tissue
that you see in the penis it gets erect
with arousal and it is it actually
extends very deep into the pelvis so
it's not just a small little organ it's
actually quite long and so you can in
men you can have erectile dysfunction
because you can see it but in women you
may have difficulty with orgasm and it's
not exactly a parallel but difficulty
orgasming in women is multifactorial and
we can get into that but I think they're
they're they're different and I think
also sexual dysfunction presents
differently in both genders so when you
talk about men they're very the one
visual they see of arousal is erections
and so it becomes very ingrained in your
psyche that if I don't have an erection
I'm not aroused right but there's a lot
of reasons that you might not have an
erection that we've sort of touched on
vascular problems hormonal problems
neurologic problems psychogenic issues
and other medications you're taking so
there are issues that can affect
erectile function and and so that can be
part of it where you know you might feel
like you have low desire because your
arousal is not there and that becomes a
little bit confusing for women what they
can assess is their level of lubrication
if sex hurts and if they get an orgasm
and so those are kind of the ways you
can look at it thank you for flushing
all of that out
you know years ago I worked on sexual
differentiation and in particular the
role of hormones in sexual
differentiation and indeed as you
described we learned because we were
taught and I think people still
generally agree that if one looks at the
embryological origins of the penis and
the clitoris they are essentially
analogous structures and that a lot of
male genital development involves
literally the regression The
Disappearance of the female sexual
genitalia and Associated or it's
mullerian ducts and things like that and
what would become the ovaries become the
testes etc etc
those are anatomical parallels but what
you just described for us very
beautifully is the sort of functional
parallels as it relates to sexual
function and dysfunction so I'm hoping
with that framing that we can
that we can knock down a few of these
pins uh in a little less time because
there's a lot to tackle here first off
I'd like to address the hormonal issues
you mentioned that only three percent of
erectile dysfunction and
by extension can we say also female
issues with sexual arousal are hormonal
in origin is that right
so with desire yes okay they are
hormonal in in general and arousal in
terms of lubrication if you're using
that as a as a barometer yes you can see
less vaginal lubrication due to hormones
and I guess I would say three to six
percent more you know up to six percent
we see of erectile dysfunction is
hormonal it's a small percentage of the
entire entirety of erectile dysfunction
okay so I think in looking on the
landscape of social media podcasts and
and just in the common
um mindset we've all come to believe
that testosterone is pro libido it's Pro
desire in men and women I think now
people are starting to appreciate that
it's Pro desire and women as well
um but certainly in men and that
dopamine is also associated with desire
and the general public tends to have
this view of estrogen as being sort of
anti-libido or anti-male which is
frankly false in fact and I've covered
this on the podcast with Dr Kyle
Gillette and with Dr Peter attia and um
another fellow YouTuber uh Derek from
more plates more dates has talked a lot
about the fact that if people if men
excuse me take drugs like an astrozole
to suppress their estrogen
thinking that oh it's all about having
high testosterone low estrogen
oftentimes they Crush their libido just
abolish it yeah which um has led to a
slowly growing but I think positive
shift in how people are thinking about
estrogen estrogen is great for brain
function estrogen is great for libido in
men and women correct um and
that is a revision of I I think how most
people think of the male sexual response
it's more in keeping with how people
think about the female sexual response
oh estrogen and the female sexual
response that that makes sense but what
we're trying to do here is clarify some
of the um misconceptions now the reason
I mentioned dopamine is that my
understanding is that dopamine is
involved in the Ural excuse me the
desire response we will distinguish
desire the psychological arousal from
genital arousal physical arousal
and that prolactin is associated with
the refractory period during which
erection can't occur another perhaps
orgasm can't occur in females Etc but
my understanding is that's also not that
simple and we need to take a step back
perhaps and just talk about the
physiological underpinnings of the
desire and arousal response so I'll tell
you what I was taught and then you can
tell me where it's wrong sure I hope I
was taught that
the erection response and the vaginal
lubrication response is generated by the
parasympathetic nervous system the
relaxed the rest and digest aspect of
the nervous system
hence why some people can get
psychogenic sexual issues of lack of
erection or lack of vaginal lubrication
but
that there are individuals out there for
whom
a lot of alertness maybe even and this
is a controversial thing but for some
people even some sense of aggression or
kind of edginess or excitement
adrenaline in other words can stimulate
erection or vaginal lubrication so it
gets tricky like it's not like the
textbooks it's not like they taught us
in high school as far as I know I was
taught that the arousal response in
males and females is initiated by a
parasympathetic sort of relaxed tone
and that as sexual desire and arousal
and sex or masturbation progresses that
it shifts more towards the sympathetic
nervous system which has nothing to do
with emotional sympathy and has
everything to do with arousal the
catecholamines dopamine norepinephrine
and epinephrine also called adrenaline
and noradrenaline are released and that
the climax response which may or may not
include ejaculation we have to separate
that out is one that is really of the
stress system of the body and then in
the post-coital or post-ejaculatory or
post climax phase
then there's a shift back to the
parasympathetic nervous system
um that's where
um the pillow talk and the uh the
exchange of uh odors and tastes and
other molecules is known to enhance pair
bonding through things like oxytocin
vasopressin and so on and what I just
described is exceedingly oversimplified
I realize but is that more or less how
the physiology works yeah so the way
we're taught in medical schools point
and shoot so point is the
parasympathetic nervous system oh you're
all the male audience will like that one
yeah and then you know you go on to the
sympathetic nervous system but it makes
sense and the reason that I think you're
hearing about this aggression or or
these things that are leading to arousal
is because there needs to be a stimulus
right a visual stimulus a tactile
stimulus some sort of stimulus that
you're getting that is then causing the
release of nitric oxide from the
parasympathetic nervous system and that
could be for some people aggression or
or you know some form of that right
people about nitric oxide because we'll
get into this when we talk about
drugs that increase blood flow Cialis
Viagra and also
um non-prescription drugs things like
l-citrulline Arginine and um watermelon
for that matter right um so I read on
the internet yeah
so yeah so nitric oxide is essentially
the ignition for what we say for
erections the ignition for erections
that we if you the reason I talk about
erections more often is when you look at
the data in fact there was a paper on
this where they looked at the number of
articles that came up when you put in
the word penis and the number of
the word clitoris and it was 50 000
about penis and 2 000 about the clitoris
okay we have to we this was actually a
major section of the comments yeah on
when I asked for for questions on
Instagram
um and comments on comments and yeah how
come
um why not Etc is that because the
Urology and um sexual health field was
dominated by men that's going to be the
presumption or is it because it's easier
to study somehow or I mean what's going
on here yeah I think there's been a lot
of
um I mean you can go back to like Freud
where he thought that that the female
sexual response was less valuable and
and so there are some some reasons
valuable I guess that's the right term
but no no I'm not challenging your term
I just ran uh you know he seemed to be
obsessed with it right but it was more
about the male sexual response than the
female sexual response and so in general
yes there is you know there were more
men in medicine there was more and it is
easier to study right you can't study
the clitoris quite as easy as you can
study the male penis response because
you can see it visually you can inject
it and see an erection response right we
do this for people who have erectile
dysfunction they'll take medications
that increase blood flow like trimix and
you'll inject it into the penis and
you'll see an erection so you can
actually try mix try mix so there's it's
in here the entire male audience just
went away so there there are there are
three basically brand names of
intracavernosal injections that we use
for erectile dysfunction I hear
injection and sickness and I I think
it's a I like to think that it reflects
a natural male response I sort of uh
um I taken aback I don't know maybe
there's a pelvic floor contractions in
there someplace so so it is it is scary
to hear about it's a very small needle
it is very well tolerated I've done it
to patients in the office and they look
at me and say you're done like they
don't even you know it's it's not as
painful as it seems and when you are not
having erections and you've tried
multiple things people get to the point
where they're willing to try that I you
know and and so it is very effective
it's the most effective non-surgical
treatment we have for erectile
dysfunction and it's usually either one
medication two medications or three so
you can have uh you know alprostadel
pavering and the third one that's a good
we can um look at someone will put it in
the comments
um uh surely they will
um what what is it designed to do is it
is it um a vasodilator of sorts so they
they work in different mechanisms but
similar to the medications that we have
pde5 Inhibitors pde5 Inhibitors work in
the erection Cascade basically what
happens let's actually let's take it
back to the nitric oxide thing we'll get
there so nitric oxide essentially is
released by the endothelium in response
to a visual tactile stimuli stimulating
cue right and so your body releases
nitric oxide which then sets off the
Cascade for the erection and so that
releases cgmp which is which is causes
the erection and it's degraded by
phosphodiesterase and so medications
that inhibit phosphodiesterase like
Viagra and Cialis tend to prevent the
breakdown of that cgmp so you have
longer lasting erections and so
similarly these medications work sort of
similar to that some of them we don't
know exactly how they work but they work
by increasing increasing cgmp or camp
that are involved in those Cascades and
what about l-citrulline I hear about
l-citrulline use it's an
over-the-counter supplement
um and it's in the Arginine pathway and
my understanding is that it works
similarly to things like uh Cialis
Viagra but is perhaps not as potent I
also just a cautionary note out there
l-citrulline can give people vicious
cold sores and canker sores vicious you
hear about this on the Internet it's
been verified by grotesque images that
you do not want to Google for
um and not everyone tolerates it well so
these actually work by increasing
nitrate side so they're not in this
they're not later down the pathway
they're actually increasingly
availability of nitric oxide so
L-Arginine is the more direct pathway
but it's very low bioavailability
l-citrulline converts L-Arginine but it
lasts much longer in the bloodstream
which is why people tend to use
l-citrulline now you know in in sexual
medicine these supplements while there's
been some studies on them and they are
effective there's no regulation on the
supplement industry so you know we can
recommend them but we just can't say
that for sure that the supplement is
exactly what's said on the bottle we see
lots of studies where they'll say you
know I read one about melatonin and
there's you know A variation of
melatonin from like what's on the bottle
to 400 times more and so that's kind of
the struggle that we as medical doctors
have and I know we get a lot of slack
for it that we don't talk about
supplements but it's really the
challenge there is like finding the
quality supplement a great site is which
I have no uh relationship to except that
I mention them all the time
um is examine.com which has references
to to human studies and where there's a
lot of efficacy shown and we'll get into
some side effect issues does can't
address you know quality by brand issues
but um thanks for mentioning that what
percentage of males who
take Cialis
um AKA tadalafel or Viagra for erectile
dysfunction get relief from that because
you mentioned only three percent of
erectile issues in males are hormonally
in origin but what percentage are likely
to be blood flow related in origin so a
large percentage of our blood flow
related that doesn't mean that the
medication will be effective for
everyone if you look at the large
percentage are are vascular in nature
right that's the number one cause in in
as men age so we know that about 50 of
52 percent of men over the age of 40
will have erectile dysfunction and that
continues to increase as you age so 50
of 50 year olds 60 of 60 year olds and
so on and so forth so it's very very
common and the success rate in the
studies is about 60 to 70 percent so
when you give someone a medication they
will have sustained erections that are
sufficient for penetrative intercourse
which is the way we kind of just discuss
erectile dysfunction in studies and in
you know with patients is is about 60 to
70 so not everyone will have success but
not all of that is because the
medication doesn't work
um sometimes people are not taking them
correctly sometimes people need to try
different Doses and then there's still
this issue of you know your brain is
still active and so if you're having
anxiety or having other issues or stress
in your life that can have an effect on
your ability to create an erection so
there's lots of factors that go into it
but generally speaking they are
effective and they do work quite well
and they're tolerated pretty well and 60
to 70 is not a small number that's
that's a significant number that's the
majority by a significant margin is
there a basis for the use of um Cialis
uh to delophyll Viagra
l-citrulline in females
yeah there there's not a lot of data on
this but certainly you know if you have
surmised that there is a blood flow
issue and they're having difficulties
with orgasm it's certainly something you
can try off label and certainly people
do try uh try these medications off
label to see if they improve sexual
function for women but there's not a
whole bunch of robust you know
randomized controlled trial studies on
women with with these medications
a little bit later we will talk about
prostate health specifically but I'm
just going to make a note here that
um nowadays there's increasing use of
low dosage
Cialis slash tadalafel so rather than
what I found online was that the
erectile dysfunction treatment dosage of
cialisa Delphos somewhere in the you
know 15 to 20 milligram range what we're
talking about here is daily use of 2.5
to 5 milligrams of sea Austin for
prostate health and I learned in
researching for this episode that
tidalophil Cialis was actually developed
as a drug for the treatment of prostate
health to
essentially increase blood flow of the
prostate to increase prostate health not
for the treatment of erectile
dysfunction so I found that to be
somewhat interesting and a lot of people
are now starting to use that I also
learned that um if you dive into the uh
the guts of the internet one can find
that now there's a growing use of
combined low dosage Cialis and April
morphine which is a pro-dopaminergic
agent and we'll get back to dopamine a
little bit later but
um is there any basis for low dosage say
2.5 to 5 milligram daily use of Cialis
to delophyll in females yes so
land females I think low-dose daily
Cialis is excellent for erectile
function in men even is that true even a
sorry to interrupt but is that true even
for men that are not experiencing
erectile dysfunction it's not indicated
for that purpose but there's a thought
that you know it's increasing blood flow
to the area so people I I've personally
used it for men who have pelvic pain to
help with increasing blood flow you can
also use it potentially as a
preventative so some people have you
know kind of thought okay it's
increasing blood flow it's preventing
fibrosis of that erectile tissue that
can happen with age or other vascular
problems so it may be beneficial for
that as well although again that's off
label and not something that we
generally promote as far as for women
there's you know again it can help with
blood flow so if you're having issues so
if you have a female who's having sexual
dysfunction and she's got signs of
vascular problems like she's got
diabetes high blood pressure she smokes
and yes it's certainly reasonable to try
and see how they do usually you want to
give at least a four-week trial to see
if there's any benefit with those
medications great thank you for that
um
why is it that I get so many questions
about erectile dysfunction from males
who are in their 20s and 30s because
everything you said up until now was
mainly focused on men 40 years and older
is it from lack of physical activity
overuse of nicotine by the way vaping as
far as we know vaping and smoking bad
for erectile function and perhaps Sexual
Health in males and females generally
because nicotine is a vasoconstrictor
nicotine does have certain benefits and
I covered this in an episode on nicotine
um neurocognitive benefits in the
elderly in particular but it is a
vasoconstrictor so it runs against all
of the sexual arousal stuff that we're
talking about
um but okay let's assume that
um uh male in their 20s or 30s is
sleeping enough
you know six to eight hours a night is
exercising isn't doing anything to
punish their pelvic floor in the gym you
know they're not doing legs cross kegels
while doing crunches or something while
inhaling on the crunch
um
that was a quiz by the way folks
um for earlier topics covered
um let's assume they're you know eating
pretty well majority of their foods are
coming from non-processed or minimally
processed foods
um they're doing a little meditation
each day they're
engaging in hopefully healthy
relationships they're not masturbating
like crazy to porn and um uh you know
let's assume that they are you know not
on any SSRI why are all these 20 and 30
year olds on the internet asking mainly
you this is they mainly run to you
um but also to my direct messages about
their erectile issues so I will say I
have seen a lot of young men in my
clinic and I will say that they very
often have pelvic floor dysfunction so
they even though they're doing all the
right things they're they do have I mean
we're in a stressful Society so you can
try all the things to be to decrease
your stress but a lot of us are sitting
long periods of time especially during
covet I mean people sat for months right
years like just sitting at their home
computer and so
um you know exercising one hour is not
going to offset the day full of sitting
and so all of those things can affect
pelvic floor function so my theory is
that that's probably the more common
cause so walk more yeah I've actually
use a standing desk yeah yep yeah walk
more standing desk
um
okay so
um and then my guess is that there's
some psychogenic feedback loop
absolutely which is just nerd speak for
things aren't working as well as they
would like then they're stressing about
it and the stress is making things worse
absolutely and you know you mentioned
that people are not masturbating or
using porn but a lot of people learn
about sex through porn whether it's good
or bad we can't you know it's not a
great thing but like that's accessible
now when we were growing up you had to
find a VCR you had to find a quiet room
that no one was going to walk in I'm old
enough to remember when the kid down the
street I won't mention them
um uh by last name but yeah the kid down
the street you know had
um porno magazines yeah or magazines and
then there was actually a library of
these goodness I shouldn't say where
they were in the town I grew up in where
kids would stash them in um in specific
locations in parking lots and then you
know boys would bike or skateboard over
or walk over and then they would like
take terms look take turns excuse me
looking at them but that that actually
is to raise uh perhaps a more important
Point
um which is that looking at pornography
is different than masturbating to
pornography which is also different than
masturbating to pornography to the point
of ejaculation right because
um I also get a lot of questions from
people about their porn addiction issues
and there's a growing Theory out there
that overuse that meaning not just
looking at but
um masturbating to pornography to the
point of ejaculation is creating a
deficit of seeking out and
um cultivating healthy real world sexual
interactions yeah so I want to I want to
start this before I get into that is is
to say that if you're masturbating to
porn and you have normal healthy
relationships and you're going to work
and you're have a great you know a
partner and everything's great in your
life it's okay like shame is a real
problem and maybe they're watching
pornography together yeah so I think you
know I think it's important though that
at least in the literature they describe
they don't describe porn addiction they
call it problematic pornography use and
it's only describing about four percent
of people in these studies so it's it's
a small subset of people I think it's
becoming more common because pornography
is so accessible and it activates the
dopamine Pathways just like any other
sort of addiction right you you watch
pornography you get a dopamine response
your brain then says Oh I wanna I want
that again and you keep seeking more
novel more aggressive different types of
pornography to get that same response
but it doesn't happen to everybody but
also I would say um sorry to interrupt
but um that the dopamine response as a
hardwired biological mechanism
for adaptive behaviors including and
let's just Define healthy sexual
behavior because I feel like
um there's such a range on that
depending on one's background religious
beliefs Etc
um anytime we talk about sex on this
podcast I like to say that involves at
least four things
obviously consensual
age-appropriate
context appropriate
species appropriate yes absolutely
absolutely that I'm really glad you
brought that up so I've heard you say
that before but it's very important and
so I think you know there is a spectrum
a large spectrum of people who watch
pornography ejaculate to pornography and
have a normal life and so that's fine I
think that you know if we shame those
people we're creating problems right we
say like oh you you do that that's
horrible and then they're in their head
right and then they're causing problems
in their life because they're because of
Shame and so there's I I think there's a
little bit of
um cultural shame that comes of this
discussion and so you know it's a
problem in the long term if we if we say
that oh this is going to create problems
because not everyone has there's so many
people who watch pornography and have no
problems who you know have normal
healthy relationships great sex with
their partner and it's fine or they're
between relationships yeah and they're
relying on masturbation specifically
right
um are there any data that distinguish
between
um Just Pure Imagination Fantasy Versus
visual fantasy as it relates to
developing or inhibiting sexual health
and here we're talking about the desire
aspect let's assume physical arousal is
you know handled so no pun intended so I
think that
um the the thing about young people I
want to get back to that then I'll
answer your question but the thing about
young people who are watching
pornography that's what they think sex
is supposed to be like they don't get an
education about what sex is right no one
has a conversation with their kids like
hey guys this is what happens when you
have sex this is how long it should take
this is what foreplay is and this is
like not normal this is the production
this is a produced product that's meant
to arouse you right and and to give you
ideally an ejaculation or an orgasm
right so
um no one has that discussion so if men
go to relationships like why did my
partner not react like that woman did on
the porno right or why did I not react
like that woman did on the porno why
didn't he reaction yeah when you know
like they would in porn because again I
think females are watching porn as well
exactly yeah you know I think so I think
that you raise a really critical point
which is that the shame can extend both
ways
and so I think to that end that's a
problem and and because it's so
accessible I think we need to have
conversations I think it needs to be
open we have to talk about sex and
that's kind of why I do what I do we
have to have these conversations so
people know what normal is thank you for
that I do think that people need to know
what normal is and what the range on
normal is keeping the constraints that
we talked about placed earlier because I
do think those are Universal healthy
constraints right consensual
age-appropriate context appropriate
species appropriate absolutely
I'd like to take a quick break and
acknowledge our sponsor inside tracker
inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
meet your health goals I'm a big
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
analyzed from a quality blood test
however with a lot of blood tests out
there you get information back about
blood lipids about hormones and so on
but you don't know what to do with that
information with inside tracker they
have a personalized platform that makes
it very easy to understand your data
that is to understand what those lipids
what those hormone levels etc mean and
behavioral supplement nutrition and
other protocols to adjust those numbers
to bring them into the ranges that are
ideal for your immediate and long-term
Health inside tracker's ultimate plan
now includes measures of both APO B and
of insulin which are key indicators of
cardiovascular health and energy
regulation if you'd like to try inside
tracker you can visit insidetracker.com
huberman to get 20 off any of inside
trackers plans again that's inside
tracker.com huberman to get 20 off I
asked whether or not
imagined the pure imagination-based
arousal versus
um visual arousal
um and for some people the sounds of of
people having sex is extremely arousing
have you ever lived in a major city
um like New York which I spent summers
in New York you hear a lot you hear more
more often than you do in
um areas where people are living further
apart you hear people having sex yeah
it's part it's part of the um part of
the auditory landscape yep you're very
close together so um but yeah so there's
not exactly at least to my knowledge I
don't know of the data that looks at
Fantasy Versus visual versus auditory
but I will say that you can get
habituated to certain things and there
is that data that maybe you can get
habituated to watching a certain type of
thing to get aroused and then normal
things do not get you aroused right like
you may watch pornography and then you
may have difficulty getting aroused or
turned on when you see your partner uh
you may get used to masturbating a
certain way right so if you use certain
vibratory stimulation or certain
pressure sensation every single time you
masturbate you can get habituated to
that and you may not be able to
replicate that during penetrative
intercourse and so I think that's really
important and I think the take home is
to try and Vary what you're doing
masturbation is find healthy way of
self-exploration again with the caveat
that as long as you're not masturbating
to excess and avoiding your obligations
or your family or your partners or your
friends right like you are just
masturbating for the benefits of maybe
sleep Improvement mood boosting
reduction in anxiety those those things
are great and so I think
um with that being said you just want to
be thoughtful about bearing it up one of
the issues with masturbation that I've
talked about when I was a guest on other
podcasts mainly in the context of male
masturbation and um perhaps with
pornography perhaps not is that it's
pretty clear based on the data
surrounding addiction
that
anytime there are big increases in
dopamine without a lot of effort
required to generate that dopamine like
turning on pornography on the internet
versus you know asking someone out on a
date going out on a date you know again
we're talking about going through the
conversations and the mating ritual that
is the human mating ritual that of
course in the context of healthy
interactions involves getting Mutual
consent and these kinds of things right
that you could imagine how without
placing any moral judgment on it without
shaming anybody you could imagine that
if somebody exclusively masturbated
and didn't develop the skills of
courtship and building healthy sexual
relationships that pornography and or
masturbation
could start to create quote unquote
problems right whereby somebody only
felt comfortable in those domains yeah
and I think that's what I'm hearing more
and more about
when it seems to be young men Reach Out
absolutely and I think you're you know
it's definitely the ease of access right
but I think that's pervasive in the
young Society now like you don't have to
actually go and find a mate you can just
go on an app and look for somebody right
like there's there's no form of finding
to make I mean I I was weaned in the era
when uh you know no smartphones or
anything and um no my point is I think
that we've become very connected to
technology in our world which also means
that we're having less conversations the
younger generation is having less
conversations and more online
conversations and I think that's a skill
that needs to be developed as well and I
think part of that is is contributing to
all this as well well one thing that I
can attest to is that you know I grew up
in a community of mostly male friends I
have free male friends always have
um where a lot of what we learned about
sex came from older my case guys
my sister probably learned a lot about
sex from her female friends
um and there was always that one guy who
would just say stuff that years later I
realized was incredibly misleading right
maybe even just detrimental
and I just want to remind people that
when you are on Reddit or anywhere on
the internet and there's
people saying things with certainty
um they might be that guy yeah right
absolutely and um and if you look at the
Lo if I look at the long Arc of those
people that guy's life it it didn't
speak to um tremendous success in the
domain for which they were asserting
such confidence let me put it that way
okay
um I'd like to slightly pivot to a
different aspect of this conversation
because it's just really critical which
is the female sexual response
you know this is something that
um does not get enough discussion
absolutely and there's a lot of
stereotypes right The Stereotype that we
hear about is oh you know they need more
foreplay which can be true some cases
is not true
um The Stereotype is that women are more
um intimacy and relationship based in
their sexual response
that can be true
I have female friends and have known
women who also are just really
interested in having sex for sex sake
at times yep or maybe all the time
um I think I like to think that we are
past the stage of human development
where the stereotypes around this are
um are fixed right and and we hear more
about this and we see more about this
now but what is the real deal around the
female arousal response and then we will
talk about female orgasm response and
there I'm just going to earmark now that
um anytime we say something like arousal
or orgasm
there are multiple forms of that right
and we will talk about the multiple
forms of female orgasm yeah so if you
talk about the response cycle you can go
back to the research of Masters and
Johnson and so what they did this was
way back when and they actually watched
sex workers have sex and this was I
guess okay female sex workers yeah with
men yeah so they watched and they took
note of the the site the kind of the
steps of the female arousal or sexual
response and so the first phase is
excitement right and during that phase
your heart rate goes up you're breathing
a little heavier there's the sex flush
you can see redness in areas like you
know in the vulva in the breast I mean
in the nipples and then you go to sort
and that can last a variety of different
times you'll also start seeing some
lubrication vaginally right and then the
plateau response is when you know that
is kind of at its peak and it kind of
stays steady and then you reach orgasm
and so orgasm essentially is a response
of the body where you will have again
increased sympathetic response and you
will have pelvic floor muscle
contractions which are rhythmic about
0.8 seconds or so you're having a
rhythmic pelvic floor contraction along
with the sensation of orgasm and then
you'll have your recovery period which
you talked about briefly earlier which
can have you know sort of a refractory
time period at which point you can no
longer you know orgasm again if you'd
like to or for men to obtain another
erection again for a short period of
time and that can be kind of an absolute
refractory period so where it's
definitely not happening and then a
relative refractory period where you'd
need something more novel and exciting
to then again resume that cycle again
the Coolidge effect yeah and we'll talk
I've talked about the Coolidge effect
before on this podcast I'll just cue
people to a a timestamp link in the show
note caption so we don't go the down the
path but one thing that's really
important to understand is that the
Coolidge effect is present in both males
and females meaning
if a male ejaculates and
um is of the feeling that they can't
have another erection for some period of
time the presentation of a novel I guess
we should say partner because we could
be talking about homosexual relationship
here not just heterosexual but
um a novel sexual partner female or male
depending on their um their proclivities
um can override the refractory period
um and they can have another erection
and ejaculation
um similarly a female will have a
post-orgasmic refractory period if
they're given an adequate stimulus right
something arousing enough
they can experience arousal and orgasm
again and we know based on really good
pharmacology that this is a dopamine
driven
um thing the prolactin is essentially
establishing the refractory period and
the dopamine is essentially overriding
the refractory period fascinating
neurochemistry there
um and it speaks to the incredible
extent to which the brain is controlling
the genitals yeah I mean we we always
say in sexual medicine that the brain is
the most powerful organ for sex not not
your genitals but the brain because it
is so powerful and I'm not sure if we're
going to touch on this later but I'll
bring it up now there are some centrally
acting medications now available for
their FDA approved for premenopausal
women with low libido oh maybe just
throw those out because the one that I'm
aware of um is uh in that's often used
in let's say Niche cultures
um is melanocyte stimulating hormone in
men which gives people a tan makes them
erect um the melanocyte stimulating
hormone and msh comes from the media
deal pituitary if I'm not mistaken one
of those weird regions no everyone talks
about anterior poster but and people are
now injecting this as a peptide it can
cause pre-opism I have not had that
experience I've never tried this um msh
but I've been told that it it people are
getting Cavalier with it they can have
issues uh pre-pism being enduring and
perhaps even final
erection is that true yeah
I mean it's actually from priapists the
Greek god who is often photographed with
a really big erection oh well we didn't
hear enough about that Greek god in
school but um or is it Roman Roman or
Greek but anyways so either way um it's
an erection that lasts longer than four
hours and it is actually a surgical or
it's not a surgical but it's actually an
emergency if you have an erection that
lasts longer than four hours in the
absence of you know sexual arousal then
it is important to get to an emergency
room because at that point you can start
developing decreased blood flow and
ultimate really no changes to the actual
tissues scarring fibrosis so it's really
important to actually go to the
emergency room don't wait because you're
embarrassed really get there and get
treated however if I'm not mistaken
earlier you mentioned that it is
exceedingly rare that people who take
Cialis slash to Dallas or Viagra for
erections are getting true priapism
correct and it's mostly from uh those
injectables we talked about earlier
those intracavernosal injections people
can get priapism from those a little bit
more commonly and so that's something we
always Counsel on and also certain
medications like trazodone or if you
have sickle cell anemia those are the
most common reasons that we see people
coming in with priorities okay I'm going
to refrain from my um desire to figure
out that one so I don't take us down a
rabbit hole here sorry I wanted to get
back to the msh there's actually an FDA
approved medication called brie
melanotide is the brand name vilisi is
the uh the sorry brie melaton is a
generic name vilisi is the brand name
which is FDA approved for women with
with low design hypoactive sexual
desired disorder premenopausal women
pre-menopausal because that's what they
studied but it is basically the same
peptide right so it is a melanocortin
receptor Agonist and it works dope you
know on the the brain Pathways to
increase desire it's taken as an
injectable again just like you said
about an hour 45 minutes before one when
you want to want you take it 45 minutes
before and it works quite effectively in
increasing desire how long does it last
about 24 hours some people may be up to
48. um has it been I mean I know of men
using melanocyte stimulating hormone
peptides I also really want to caution
people
um about obtaining gray Market peptides
sorry for this um uh insertion here but
um there are a lot of peptides available
without a prescription on the internet
they are almost all contaminated with
something called LPS Lippy
polysaccharide which is not something
you want to be injecting a lot over time
that's actually how we induce an immune
response in animals in the laboratory
and it is amazing to me how many
websites are selling this stuff and it
um arrives to you easily you just buy it
on the internet says not for human or
animal use and people are injecting it
and the LPS issue is something I think
is um potentially going to shut down
that whole Market at some point but if
you're interested in using a peptide you
should be obtaining it by a prescription
from a quality physician exactly and
because we have Brie melanotide we can
prescribe that for men as well so
sometimes we'll do it off label from men
who are having delayed ejaculation
because it will help them achieve orgasm
a little bit better and so you know this
is available for pre-menopausal women
the other uh medication that's available
for low libido is called phlebanserin
also known as Addie is the brand name
and that also works on Sarah's it's got
kind of a mixed response serotonin and
dopaminergic areas of the brain and
essentially works as a daily medication
taken before bedtime 100 milligrams a
day that actually helps with decreasing
hypoactive sexual desire disorder Works
in about 6 45 to 60 percent of patients
and you need to take it for some time
now both of these are brand name
medications so they are a little bit
costly and sometimes insurance doesn't
cover them but they are available and I
think very few people know about them
and I think they're really great and
useful tools in the toolbox and these
are for desire they're for yes they're
they're FDA approved for what we call
hypoactive sexual desire disorder which
is essentially low libido that causes
distress and bother
I don't want to take us off course about
vaginal
um lubrication arousal and female orgasm
but as long as we're talking about
arousal and
um
reduced arousal that requires treatment
I have to ask this now
anytime we talk about arousal and libido
there's no BMI which by the way the body
mass index is probably not the best tool
either but there's no chart it's not
like a thermometer that says your 98.6
plus or minus two degrees you're good if
it's too high much higher than that you
have a fever if much lower than that
you're hypothermic so my understanding
my uh I don't want to say naive
understanding but um my understanding is
that
one determines whether or not their
libido is normal high or low
largely based on some intuitive
understanding of what their partner or
partner's desire whether or not they can
meet those desires and if they sort of
uh accrue enough of a sample size they
date enough people where they have
sexual interactions they can they figure
out over time whether or not they have a
low medium or high sex drive and people
tend to compare to how they felt in
earlier years or at different times of
the year or under different
psychological conditions and stress
conditions that kind of thing but we
really don't have a benchmark for this
right I mean we can't say that for
instance that if uh people are not
Desiring sex or thinking about sex with
blank frequency that they have low
libido right it's sort of what is
working or not working for you in the
context of your life right is that is
that yes there's no right or wrong
basically what you're saying there's no
right or wrong amount of libido there's
many people who identify asexual and
they are happy with that there are
people who like to to have sex once a
month and they're happy with that it
really is a matter of distress are you
bothered by it so when we look at
studies for female sexual dysfunction
you can using like validated
questionnaires like the fsfi you can
actually see that about 40 percent of
people qualify for having sexual
dysfunction but really bother is only
seen in about 12 percent and you can be
bothered because you're bothered you can
be bothered because your partner is
bothered but it's really up to you right
like if you feel like there's something
that you want to improve on then that's
when you go see your doctor but there's
no right or wrong answer right this is
very subjective and a lot of times we'll
see couples who have mismatched libidos
now does that mean one person's right
and one person is wrong no it's just a
matter of like well how do you if you
want to come to a point where you agree
how do we get there you know and what is
what is your end goal yeah I later we'll
talk a little bit more about chemistry
which I find infinitely fascinating
because in my life experience I've just
been struck by the fact that occasion
only you have a physical interaction
with someone or sometimes it's not even
physical interaction and they are just
so unbelievably arousing to you or
somewhere in between or sometimes it it
just sort of ain't there or it's just
not there that much or nobody likes to
talk about this or it's there until you
sleep together and then it's not there
and this is all not just put on males
this is put on females i i
she doesn't kill me for saying this
I know somebody who is a family member
who once said sometimes you have to
realize you never want to sleep with
somebody Again by Sleeping with them and
here we're not talking about traumatic
experience right right so you know again
the discussion around libido as you um
so aptly pointed out engaging what is
healthy levels of libido has a lot to do
with what one's self-desires as well as
the hopes and expectations of the people
that we are sexually involved with so
we'll get back to that a little bit
later in the context of chemistry
because I find it so fascinating and
it's something that isn't talked about
enough
but thank you for that
um let's get back to
female sexual arousal response and
orgasm so physiologically what happens
to the body is It prepares for
penetration now that could be a penis
that could be a sex toy that could be a
digit finger to be more specific so it
what it does is the cervix moves up and
out of the way the the inner one-third
two-thirds of the vagina lengthens and
elongates to allow for penetration and
it can actually double nearly double in
size of the of the Baseline vaginal
length and so it is preparing for that
so if you and so that's part of it in
some people who have Painful intercourse
it's because they haven't had adequate
time for arousal and so they're the
penis is penetrating before they've had
those adaptations to occur and also the
labia open up to allow for that
penetration so these things actually
happen physiologically to allow for
Preparation so while some people may be
aroused and get to that point quicker
some people do need a longer period of
time of what as you described before
play and not everyone is is the same but
I think it's important to have that
discussion with your partner and you
know lubrication is one of the ways that
people assess arousal but that's not the
be-all end-all some people just make a
lot of lubrication and some people don't
and certainly that changes with age and
hormones so if um certainly we know that
after menopause with a drop in estrogen
and testosterone you will see a decrease
in lubrication and sometimes if people
are on medications that can alter their
hormonal access they may also see
changes in lubrication after during
breastfeeding you can see changes in
lubrication and again this is not a
they're not aroused necessarily this is
like a physiologic problem that they're
having can we distinguish between
arousal-based lubrication let's say
sexual arousal based lubrication and
again folks forgive me for being so
hyper-specific in language but there are
other forms of arousal besides sexual
arousal that we know from it's not a
pleasant topic from reports uh following
sexual assault that you know oftentimes
the victim is demonized for having been
lubricated and they will say well then
people will presume that somehow they
wanted that interaction and that's not
true in those cases it's clear that
those that the lubrication occurred
independent of libido type arousal
exactly right okay so let's set that
aside again unpleasant topic but one
that's important to to um to flag
are there forms of non-libido
type arousal
lubrication that allow for non-painful
or even pleasureful
penetration
that
are important to distinguish from the
arousal based lubrication in other words
I have to imagine
that women will
have sex and it can be pleasureful or at
least not painful and that might relate
in some way to Baseline levels of
lubrication and here we've been talking
about lubrication mainly in the context
of arousal you know post-menopausal
reductions in lubrication but are there
also postmenopausal reductions in
Baseline lubrication are some people's
vaginas just more lubricated at
um I won't say at rest it's like a
scientist in me um when um they're
asleep for instance I mean men are
having erections in their sleep are
women getting vaginal lubrications in
their sleep periodically my guess is yes
well they're definitely getting clitoral
in engorgement right they're getting
clear engorgement there's been some
studies on that that they are also
getting nocturnal tumescence right just
like men do as far as lubrication you
know the the data at least from what I
understand is like there is a protective
mechanism whereby women when when
there's any sense that there may be
penetration that their body will
immediately start creating lubrication
and that is productive to avoid you know
trauma and injury there's also Baseline
vaginal discharge that's completely
normal women will make physiologic
discharge in fact in our examinations
when we examine we'll say normal
physiologic discharge because we see it
there's always discharge and it is um it
can be up to like five milliliters and
so it's not a small amount it can happen
it can be quite a lot it needs menstrual
cycle dependent in terms of the
viscosity and the yes it changes over
the cycle and it can be different in
color and different in thickness and
that's completely normal and I think
that's a real problem in the feminine
hygiene industry
um you don't need to smell a certain way
or or reduce that discharge this is like
completely normal healthy and you talked
about chemistry and I know there's like
not a ton of data on this but there's
like pheromones right there's scents
that are coming from you which are
actually attractive to a partner
potentially and and in whatever
physiologic you know I don't know
there's not a lot of data on this but
like there is that part of it so
um you know there's a lot of marketing
towards women that you're dirty you
should be smelling like peaches or
whatever and there's a lot of marketing
maybe this is generational thing but I I
learned early on I think about
behavioral Neuroscience courses that
vaginal lubrications were
um part of the arousal response for both
um these were always framed in the
context of heterosexual relationships
but both Partners let's just say both
Partners um because this could be a
homosexual female relationship too right
we want to make the conversation as
broad as possible
um and that the odor let's just be frank
here um the odor and The Taste
um played a role in both arousal but
also the pair bonding response that
would establish future arousal and
anyone that's ever been in a um in a
relationship that uh let's say you had
healthy sexual relations I like to think
his experience I'm remembering
somebody's smell or thinking about
somebody's smell and that itself can be
very arousing yes Partners even I'm
smelling uh different articles of each
other's clothing and that being arousing
so I mean this is the stuff of of real
physiology we're not we're not making
this stuff up right but there is there
is a lot of marketing towards women that
they should use douching or other things
to clean themselves and it is it's
damaging right it's actually one it can
affect the vaginal microbiome so their
pH is changing and that can affect you
know their risk for UTIs or bacterial
vaginosis and um and and so they're
they're buying these spending their
money on these things because they're
being told that they're not clean and
they come to the doctor saying oh I'm
you know I think I have a STD but it's
like normal physiologic discharge
um and so I think it's important to say
that this is normal and and it's normal
to have an odor that is distinct to you
and that there's you know of course if
you have like a fishy odor that may be a
sign of like a very strong new novel
odor that wasn't there before that may
be a sign of a sexually transmitted
infection but if it's your general odor
that you've always had that's normal
what about other infections like yeast
infections or bacterial infections of
the um I got a number of questions about
mycoplasma infections which you know we
don't hear that often about but um yeah
so you you can see if your discharge has
changed and become more like Cottage
cheese-like or there's um you know other
symptoms like itching
um or discomfort then you know those are
signs to go get evaluated a mycoplasma
is another infection that we see in the
vagina but we also actually sometimes
see in the urine and while it's not
something we routinely test for when we
have people who have symptoms of urinary
tract infection and they're not
improving sometimes they will check for
you mycoplasma that could be causing
symptoms in the urethra itself we've had
a couple episodes about the gut
microbiome my colleague Justin
Sonnenberg at Stanford whose laboratory
is directly above for my his expert in
the gut microbiome I've done a couple
episodes about this and um he reminded
me and I like to remind people that
every mucosal lining of your body has a
robust microbiome so that means
intranasal and true vaginal intra
urethral in males and females there's an
anal microbiome there's a microbiome on
your skin on your eyes
and you mentioned douching and other uh
and other ways of I want to say quote
unquote cleaning it because that
language Falls in line with the idea
that it's a good thing you're telling me
it's it's a bad thing in many cases
um because it's wiping out the
microbiome what are some of the things
that females can do in order to promote
the health of their vaginal microbiome
so it's it's really our bodies are
amazing the vagina is a self-cleaning of
it you don't have to do anything you
just watch that the vagina is a
self-cleaning oven I'm not gonna I'm not
going to repeat that too often in too
many different contexts but I'm going to
remember it forever you will you will
and so all you need to do is wash the
hair bearing areas because those are the
ones that create sweat and and and
should be cleaned but other than that
let soapy water run down you don't need
to do anything your body will take care
of it itself when I was five years old I
pulled my parents in the bathroom and I
said they still talk about this I said I
want to know everything about sex I want
to know everything and they were like oh
my God what are we dealing with and I'll
never forget my dad just looked at me
he's Argentina he said Just remember
kids are the one thing in life you can't
give back that's all he said that was it
that's it that was it oh gosh yeah well
I will tell you my discussions with my
sons are my son my older son has been
much more graphic than that I tell him
amazing yeah amazing well I went out
into the world and uh anyway
um you figured it out
let's spend a few minutes or more
talking about female orgasm
one of the more cryptic topics on the
internet
not because it isn't discussed but
because I think that the Nuance of it
isn't discussed often enough or in full
depth so let's take the time we need um
to parse this
I think that the simplest way to parse
it is going to be from the anatomical
standpoint
clitoral orgasm versus so-called G-spot
or penetration-based orgasm but of
course penetration-based orgasm is also
a bit of a misnomer because there can be
clitoral stimulation by pelvic pressure
or by digit we're talking about fingers
it's digits because we're both in the
Medical Science profession but we're
talking about fingers here or something
else right vibrator toy whatever I'm toe
for it depends on how flexible you are I
don't know but the point being
um that I think the simplest way to go
about this is going to be to talk about
the distinction between clitoral orgasm
and G-spot orgasm
however those are achieved
um
and to also talk about this idea of
graded versus absolute okay so this has
actual parallels to Neuroscience where
we talk about communication between
neurons being graded meaning it's kind
of you know one level then a higher
level than a lower level or all or none
right
um how should I say this
um it is clear in my life experience and
observation that there are multiple
kinds of female orgasm those that are
graded and in some cases cumulative they
sort of build towards a larger and
larger orgasm and then there are what
some people have described as Cliff type
orgasms where there's a refractory
period
I think that's a fair way to frame this
and clearly there are different
responses to the orgasm response some
people get sleepy some people get
energized some people it heightens their
desire for more some people they need a
a period of time in which um they become
hypersensitive to touch
um so uh lots of different things going
on there psychologically physiologically
um
yeah tell us all of it so in terms of
orgasm right I think it's important to
distinguish that there is orgasm and
then there's different areas that you
stimulate to achieve orgasm so some
people will stimulate the clitoris is
probably the most reliable form of
stimulation that will achieve orgasm and
when you look at the data and again you
know female sexual dysfunction data is
not super robust but what we find is
that about 85 percent of women require
clitoral stimulation in order to climax
so very few actually climax through just
vaginal penetration alone and so this is
you know a real problem we're seeing on
the media that you know you you have sex
and you penetrate and immediately women
are having orgasms that's not the
reality for a lot of women and in terms
of stimulation so like we've talked
about throughout this podcast the
clitoris is the homologue of the penis
or the penises the homologous the
clitoris however you want to say it good
on you for getting it both directions
yeah I probably would have screwed that
one up yeah so um so clitoral
stimulation is just like penile
stimulation for women that is very
reliable and there's a huge orgasm gap
for men it's pretty consistent that when
they have a first time sexual encounter
95 of men are having an orgasm when you
look at first-time sexual encounters for
women with in heterosexual relationships
it's about 45 to 50 percent are having
an orgasm and when you look at
homosexual relationships of women it's
again 90 so there's clearly some lacking
in ninety percent of
um female homosexual interactions that
are first-time interactions 90 percent
are having orgasm correct presumably
because they understand the anatomy of
other by way of understanding the
anatomy of self so there's a huge
but you know there's a huge gap and so I
think to to bring it home is the
clitoral stimulation is the most
reliable way and as you mentioned when
you're stimulating vaginally you're
often the clitoris is like a wishbone
and it goes around the vagina and so
you're often stimulating those the Kura
is what we call the legs I guess for
lack of a better term of the clitoris
and so you're stimulating that you're
also stimulating the clip the clitoral
shaft which goes deep into the pelvis
the G-Spot is
um is an area as a neurogenous Zone
where it's kind of in the anterior wall
of the vagina about two to three
centimeters in that's the location of
these periathral glands called the
skene's glands and they are analogous or
homologous to the male prostate so just
like some men have prostate play and
enjoy pleasure from prostate stimulation
some women enjoy G-spot stimulation now
that's not Universal right not all men
enjoy prostate play and not all women
are going to be aroused by G-spot
stimulation and so I think there's a
huge huge uh huge variety of ways you
can stimulate what stimulate anyone it
can be man or woman some people will
have orgasms through just nipple
stimulation alone some will just hear
something or see something and be able
to achieve an orgasm and it's it's so
varied from person to person and I think
that the big take home from this for
people listening is like you have to
talk to your partner and this is the
hardest thing we never learned how to
talk about sex like what do you like
what do you not like and and don't take
it personally right like I think a lot
of times people feel like you have to
orgasm to have pleasure which may not be
the case for everybody and if it is you
know how do you prioritize that for your
relationship so I don't know if I got
off track there but that's kind of
um I think the the take-homes for this
and also the vaginal penetration it's
actually usually from cervical
stimulation not necessarily vaginal
because the large density of innervation
of the vagina is in the first outer
third of the vagina the the deeper
two-thirds of the vagina has has much
less Innovation and yet there is such a
thing as cervical orgasm so and the
cervix being further up the vaginal
Canal
um is cervical orgasms specifically the
what if the stimulation and act uh the
foci of an orgasm that starts in the
back of the vagina is that yeah so
stimulation of the
through whatever means right and that
can be pleasurable and lead to orgasm
and again orgasm you know is is defined
differently right but the one thing we
know is that there are pelvic floor
contractions which are measurable so you
can kind of tell that your partner is
having an orgasm if you have a female
partner because you can actually feel
those contractions right whether it's on
your digit or your organ or a sex toy
okay super nerdy question here
um years ago when I worked on
hormone-based sexual differentiation
which by the way we've done a episode of
the podcast on previously
um
uh you know I learned that the levatory
any muscle
um is the muscle that controls erection
in males and presumably uh clitoral
tumescence and an engorgement in females
is there an equivalent muscle
responsible for the orgasm response or
is the contraction of the pelvic floor
um part of a more General theme of of
muscular contraction and a bunch of
different nerve Roots Contracting the
reason I asked this is that eventually
in this conversation we're going to
migrate up toward the brain but because
this is a science and health podcast
when we talk about orgasm of course many
people recognize that as their
experience of it and their recognition
of it in other people
um and descriptions Etc but
um are we talking about a response that
originates at a Foci
um kind of like in a in the brain we
talk about a seizure you know starting
at a focus a Foci and then spreading out
um or are we talking about a bunch of
different nerve roots and brain centers
firing in synchrony and that's why some
people experience it as you know behind
their forehead and in their genitals or
as a whole body response and here we're
not talking about the flood of of
neurochemicals into the body I'm talking
about during those moments of orgasm
um what is happening neurally I mean it
does have certain parallels to seizure
right it does it does so let me go back
to your first part of the question which
was um about orgasm and sorry erection
and tumescence being related to levator
A9 so actually what happens during the
reason you get an erection and
presumably clear stimulation the same
way is blood flows into the erectile
tissue and the Tunica which is the outer
layers of the of the of the erectile
tissue which are two basically
cylindrical shape structures in the
penis and in the clitoris they will fill
with blood and then that Tunica will
compress veins on the outside to prevent
blood flow from leaving so it's not a
muscular event it's an actual blood flow
event then how come when we wanted to
study erection behavior in rodents we
would
um give them injections of testosterone
females or males and observe
changes in sexual behavior accordingly
erection and clitoral tumescence
although it's harder harder to measure
in rodents there's a way of indirectly
measuring that and then we would measure
the the size and weight of the levator
Annie muscles as a readout of how
androgenized that whole system was you
know in other words what is the role of
the laboratory Annie in in the sexual
response so the levator Ani
well you would know I I still think so
those muscles are part of the pelvic
floor right and so those contract when
you when you climax right so whether
it's orgasm for male or female they're
Contracting and they're exercising right
they're get so that's how they would
increase their their strength or their
density if you're measuring that through
the actual climax of which you can't see
in rodents right so like you're kind of
using it as a surrogate in that way so
that's what happens those muscles
contract as a response and climax is a
brain initiated event orgasm is a brain
initiated event so that's why to answer
your second part you obviously feel
focal response but you also can feel a
variety of responses because it's all
coming from the brain it's not a kind of
the the way you described it as like a
ripple effect
um it's more of like uh it it's the way
your body responds to that particular
stimuli and it's actually like the
ultimate form of mindfulness you can't
think of anything else when you're
orgasming right so it's like you have
this Moment of clarity and and every and
and everything you were very present in
that moment and so people will feel
different stimulations depending on you
know how they're how they kind of how
they're censored you know their nerves
are their Sensations are and things like
that
um it's perhaps a good time to um
mention dopamine we talked about it a
few times
um earlier when talking about the
arousal Arc that starts with
parasympathetic sort of calm and then
um move typically starts as calm and
then moves to
um
the orgasm response we know that the
orgasm response is associated with
release of dopamine
and then prolactin which sets up the
relative or absolute refractory period
the uh the interesting thing and I got
some questions about this is that um
there's literature as I understand about
the
elevation and dopamine caused by say
antidepressants like Wellbutrin buprin
which increases dopamine and
norepinephrine
um people who recreationally use drugs
like cocaine or other stimulants people
who take Adderall Vyvanse or other drugs
that increase levels of dopamine because
I did a whole episode about those drugs
and they are different forms of
amphetamine unless we're talking about
Ritalin which is a little bit different
and I got a lot of questions about
people who experience feeling a lot of
Desire sort of arousal but not being
able to achieve the physical arousal
erection or vaginal lubrication so it's
almost as if they're sitting further
along that arousal Arc hence the
importance I think of people learning to
have calm
states of mind when going into sexual
interactions now I realize that in
saying that it might be confusing
because a lot of people think well
that's anything but calm right sexual
arousal is anything but calm but
maintaining enough calm that they can
ride that Arc
um for whatever duration is appropriate
for that interaction in them right
because again and we should probably get
back to this you know
um you know some people will have sex
for long periods of time some for
shorter periods of time and here
people don't really know what other
people are doing except by way of
pornography and self-report and
discussion so um
is it the case that drugs that increase
dopamine can inhibit the sexual response
do they tend to promote the sexual
response because I also mentioned
earlier there's this growing trend of
people taking by way of prescription of
course from a physician combined
apomorphine which is a dopaminergic drug
um with tidalophil which is a pde5
inhibitor so it's going to increase
blood flow and I'm hearing about men and
women but mainly men doing this so
ramping up their dopamine
ramping up their blood flow to their
genitals in order to have presumably
more arousal in sex does that make sense
uh um yes as a mechanism yes so in terms
of apromorphine the that has been
studied and it's mostly been approved
outside of the United States so we don't
use it very often here in the United
States because it hasn't been FDA
approved but you know it's a very
complex responsible like I mentioned
that um phlebanserin which is
essentially acting medication it
actually has not only um inhibitory and
not only stimulatory but also inhibitory
effects on dopamine so the way it sort
of works to enhance interest or libido
is sort of complex and kind of confusing
the when it was actually approved it was
it was being studied for an
antidepressant and what they found was
that women were actually having you know
better interest in sex or more interest
in sex and so that's kind of how it was
discovered similarly Viagra was actually
studied for high blood pressure and when
they went to
um it was horrible blood pressure
medication but then the people the men
who took it actually didn't return the
samples for the study so they realized
like what's going on here and it was
because they were having better
erections is it true that
um at some Urology meeting that the
first
description of Viagra as a treatment for
erectile dysfunction involved the
speaker actually coming out from behind
the podium and revealing his erection is
that a true story yes I don't think it
was Viagra I think it was an intricate
cavernosal injection though I think he
came out
um it is the true story there's actually
a published article I'll send it to you
so you can share it if you'd like to see
it but I'll read the article there's a
there's a published article about people
who were attending at the meeting and
yes he came out and at the time like it
was mostly men in urology but there were
like spouses I guess in the audience
which is not typical now but
um so there were women in the audience
and he came out with a full-on erection
to show that it you know it worked well
I suppose that the Urology meeting
um or OB GYN meeting where a woman comes
out and reveals her enhanced vaginal
lubrication then we will have um we will
have a gender and sex balance at the
meetings on Urology
um it'll be interesting to attend one of
those someday
um
differences in arousal as a function of
stage of the menstrual cycle
really interested in this I did a long
episode on fertility and we're going to
have a few other IVF experts fertility
experts on the podcast
um but
clearly
um there are differences in hormones
across the menstrual cycle we know that
for sure yeah um
clearly there can be psychological
variation according to those hormones
but probably other things across the
menstrual cycle and it's always an
imperfect experiment because
you know we aren't laboratory rats and
people are having different interactions
across the menstrual cycle is there any
known correlation between desire
and stage of the menstrual cycle there
are some obvious um assumptions that one
might make you know prior to ovulation
Etc around the time of obligation
um but what about the other direction
too
um is there a category of women that are
very interested in sex at certain stages
of the menstrual cycle and then not at
all interested in sex at other stages
the menstrual cycle you know all that
other and maybe a gynecologist could
speak
and study those variations a little
better but there is data to suggest that
libido does increase prior to ovulation
and during ovulation I think it's like a
couple days prior because that's the
optimal time for fertility so yes there
is data to suggest that in terms of like
completely
lack of Interest I don't believe there's
data but I'm not not sure is there
evidence that females who perhaps have
not experienced so-called G-spot orgasm
or cervical orgasm can learn to do that
and I always find it interesting that
whenever there's a discussion about
different forms of female orgasm people
are
careful to point out that many women
don't have penetration-based orgasm and
then they separate out clitoral
stimulation as more a more common route
to orgasm but of course there can be
clitoral stimulation with penetration
absolutely right and depending on the
your physical arrangement there can be
clitoral stimulation purely by way of
penetration through pelvic contact
um you know fingers Etc so yeah so how
do we how should we think about this how
should we talk about it so there was an
interesting study that I just read
recently where they they gave women
words for these things right so
um they there's like the rocking
stimulation so that can also stimulate
so meaning that the you're penetrating
but there's like a rocking motion that
can also penetrate the clitoris there's
um stimulation of just the outer part of
the vagina which again as I mentioned
the G-Spot is there it's more highly
innervated so that can be more
stimulating there's also ways to align
yourself so that when you're penetrating
you're putting pressure on the clitoris
and then there's you know stimulation
with like actual stimulation of the
clitoris like intentional stimulation
either by yourself or by the partner and
so there are multiple different ways to
do that right
um and so there I think that it's
important to really
um kind of it's okay to explore and not
always be a home run and I think that's
like when you get into a relationship
where you're maybe second third fourth
time having intercourse with someone
that you can try and explore these
different things or if the partner
themselves knows what they like to
actually tell the other partner right
there's a huge part of communication
that I think is is plays a huge role in
this because we know ourselves better
than anyone else so you can tell your
partner what you like and I think that
that we have never been taught how to do
that
yeah
um such important conversations for so
many reasons as you point out um
definitely not something they teach
people in school except you know they
might say something about you know
communication is important and that
almost always circles back to the the
key four things we talked about earlier
which is you know consent and
age-appropriate context appropriate
these kinds of things and um and
obviously substances like Alcohol and
Other Drugs can strongly confound those
issues and so that's we'll just leave
that as a as a kind of an obvious one
um as long as we're talking about
communication around sexual interactions
um perhaps it would be useful to people
to cultivate a language or a
nomenclature there too to facilitate
that
um some of the language that I've heard
that is quite useful is things like um
you know people have different arousal
templates right some people certain
ideas are stimulating to them and other
ideas are reversive to them and then
there's this category in between where
sometimes people sort of either don't
know because they haven't tried it or
haven't thought about it or they're sort
of curious but kind of unsure or it
might work in the right context but
maybe not all the time yeah um so is
there any kind of structure that's been
put out there as a way to improve
communication around sexual interactions
yeah I mean there's no like script but I
think in general you want to have the
conversation outside of the bedroom so
not like right before sex or right after
sex because that leads to like a you
know a sense of insecurity for the other
person right did I do something wrong
did something go wrong here so you want
to kind of move those to a neutral
location so like kitchen table in the
car whatever somewhere where you know
sex is not going to happen
um at least for that particular moment
and um listening
um we've been some challenging
conversations on this podcast challenge
uh previously challenging because they
you know you're trying to get things
clear and uh as clear as possible um
this one is challenging because there's
so many caveats to everything right we
don't of course people have sex in cars
right yeah um or they did when I was
growing up
um and sometimes they still do
um okay please continue yes so that's
one and then two like when you're
discussing it I mean this is kind of
goes for any difficult conversation is
like you make I statements right you say
I I like it when this I don't like it
with this it's not something you did
right it's not you didn't do this you
didn't do that it makes kind of an
animosity sort of situation and then you
know I think also part of it is like
being open about those things and it may
it's not going to happen in one
conversation I think that's the hard
part like you think you're going to have
a conversation it's going to go great
and things are going to be better it's
going to be like multiple conversations
and some of them are not going to go
well right so like
um that's another place where you can
actually get the help of a sex therapist
and there is a website for that it's
a-a-s-e-c-t-asect.org where you can look
for a sex therapist near you and you can
even do those things virtually and so
that can be really helpful when you're
having difficulty having a conversation
yeah I think um again such important
conversations and then when people
differ in terms of their level of
experience it gets um potentially
problematic but also it can be
potentially educational
and then of course they're the twists
and turns that occur with when one is
asking about somebody else's arousal
template oftentimes you'll learn things
about people's sexual past and that can
be either neutral stimulating or
aversive right that can open up all
sorts of other issues related to the
psychological interplay so there's no
way we can parse all of those now I just
think it's worth highlighting
um that it's understandable why those
conversations are challenging
um and it also is understanding why
pornography isn't going to involve those
conversations right right the only
conversations there are between your
brain your hands and your eyes and your
ears um uh not going to highlight any
particular order there
um
I want to switch gears slightly and talk
about UTIs I got a lot of questions
about urinary tract infections let's
make it
related to both females and males
because yes males get urinary tract
infections females get them more females
asked about urinary tract infections how
common are they should they always be
treated with antibiotics is cranberry
really a good treatment if so why are
there other things that are better is it
relates to the acidity or alkalinity
um
how does one prevent getting UTIs can
you get them from swimming should you
urinate after sex
tell us about UTIs and how not to get
them and how to get rid of them happy to
so UTIs are very common in women
probably up to 50 of women get at least
one UTI in their lifetime and up to a
third of them get recurrent UTIs and
what that means is they have two or more
in six months or three or more in a year
now this is common and so we'll see a
lot of it and it's not as until you're
having recurrent utsc you just have one
a year or you have one every few years
it's not a huge issue in men however
UTIs are much less common and that's
because the urethra is longer so there's
less entry from the outside world into
the bladder which causes infections and
so
um the when men go to UTI it's
concerning like why is a man getting a
UTI you know there's multiple reasons
that it could happen but it should be
investigated like so that you can make
sure there's no anatomic abnormality or
functional abnormality with a bladder
that's causing the UTIs in terms of
prevention there are kind of major
things that are had in the guidelines
that we all we all talk about so one is
hydration so making sure you're drinking
about two to three liters of fluid
ideally water a day because dilution is
the solution to the pollution right so
drinking more fluids is going to get
that bacteria and you're going to pee it
out it's going to help keep not let it
sit around in the bladder very often
another thing in women who have Altered
States of estrogen whether it's
post-menopausal surgical menopause or
maybe have a reduced estrogen for
postpartum or other reasons but what
about you in the second half of the
menstrual cycle not necessarily for
those specific people but for those
specific times but because it's pretty
short-lived I guess you could use it but
um is vaginal estrogen so vaginal
estrogen meaning estrogen that's applied
in the vagina either through a cream a
suppository or a ring is is highly
effective in reducing the occurrence of
recurrent UTIs and this is because when
you have low estrogen the pH in the
vagina goes up and the pH in the vagina
goes up because there's less conversion
of glycogen to lactobacilli and then
those lactobacilla are preventative for
UTIs so essentially you want to reduce
the pH back to its normal acidic pH and
vaginal estrogen is very effective at
doing that fact in our clinics will
actually check a vaginal pH you know to
see if there is an indication that their
pH is too high that maybe they do need
vaginal estrogen particularly around
like perimenopause because it's hard to
tell just by looking if they are really
um heading into a lower estrogen State
sometimes and so that's very very
effective and very very safe so when you
look at estrogen you know the the
Women's Health Initiative way back when
sort of made a big stink about how
estrogen is related to cancer
however vaginal estrogen has never ever
been a reported breast cancer uterine
cancer or any other blood clot any other
adverse event associated with vaginal
estrogen you can get some breast
tenderness some discharge those things
can occur but the absorbed amount
vaginally is so little that your
estrogen level barely goes up it doesn't
even reach pre-menopausal levels so it
just goes up very slightly in the
bloodstream not enough to create any
sort of abnormality so a vaginal
astronaut is extremely safe and it's
pretty affordable you could actually use
coupons if your insurance doesn't cover
it through you know GoodRx or Mark
Cuban's pharmacy and get it very very
affordably and it's very effective it
does take about three months to work so
you know you have to be consistent you
apply it about twice a week at night
sometimes three times a week and it's
very effective the ring you put in once
and it lasts for three months but so
generally speaking that's the most
effective option for low estrogen States
other kind of simple things are trying
to make sure you're completely emptying
your bladder so over a lifetime people
can develop some mild pelvic floor
dysfunction right not enough to create
pain or discomfort but maybe they're not
emptying completely right because maybe
they used to hold their urine for long
periods of time when they were a kid or
maybe they're always hovering over the
toilet because they don't want to sit on
it at work and over time that can create
a little bit of mild dysfunction which
can make it more difficult to completely
empty the bladder and when urine is
sitting in the bladder for long periods
of time it's basically food for bacteria
to grow and so bacteria grows and then
you get recurrent UTI so making sure
you're completely empty by sitting
relaxing on the toilet sometimes leaning
forward and then maybe going a second
time so standing up sitting back down
going again and even for men sometimes
trying to sit and see if you completely
empty because sometimes standing you're
not able to empty completely whoa a lot
of men are gonna because they're these
you know it was fun to research for this
episode because
um there are entire discussions on
Reddit about like what percentage of
males sit while urinating I mean my
understanding based on having visited
many male bathrooms in my lifetime and
um just being in the world um that that
I assumed that men stood up in order to
to urinate but there are a decent
percentage of men that sit down to
urinate there are and in fact it's
variable like country and probably the
reason it's become more interesting
lately
so a certain country was recently
surveyed I think it was Germany
um but essentially this recent like
picked up by the media that Germans sit
more often to pee and so you know then
people like oh is this better for me to
sit to pee or stand to pee and there's
this whole big discussion on the media
but the reason being is when you're
sitting your pelvic floor is most
relaxed and so if you're having any
issues emptying your bladder you're
gonna pee better also if you have an
enlarged prostate which I'm sure we're
going to talk about prostate enlargement
that can sometimes allow you to develop
a little bit more abdominal pressure
because you're sitting and you can lean
forward to overcome sort of a blockage
and and so there are some some
indications were sitting is better but
if you're peeing fine and you're
standing that's fine too I don't think
you have to I think it's just something
that you know in other countries they do
more and here we don't and I don't think
it's right or wrong it just depends on
your individual circumstance
can
spermicides or condoms or both increase
the frequency of UTIs for females so
spermicides absolutely so spermicides if
your condom has spermicide on it or
you're using spermicides that is a known
risk factor for UTIs other things I want
to touch on you did ask about cranberry
so cranberry is actually in the American
Urological Association guidelines for
prevention of recurrent UTIs in women
now how does cranberry work right like
do I just bring juice it's actually a
specific active ingredient in the
Cranberry which is called
proanthocyanidins or Pacs and in order
they've actually looked at the amount of
Pacs you need and what formulation so
you need 36 milligrams of Pacs in a
soluble form so a lot of the supplements
on the market will say that they're 36
milligrams of Pacs but they're like the
whole Berry so they're using the the
skin of the berry and the stem of the
berry and that's not going to help you
so you need to make sure that the
supplement you're using is a soluble
form of the cranberry and it's actually
very very very effective at reducing the
risk of UTIs so do you mean um capsules
like a gel cap yeah it's a capsule that
you take once a day and there is some
although not as much data that if you're
having them around sex which some women
do always have post-coital UTIs that you
can take two on the day of sex and two
on the day after and that may be helpful
but there's not a lot of data there but
certainly an option that you can try
that's pretty low risk so that's kind of
the the guidelines now there's a ton of
other things that you can do to help
prevent that are kind of available and
have some data behind them so d-mannose
is one of them where you take you know
about two grams a day of d-mannose and
you drink it and that actually helps
reduce UTI risk it's been studying a
small randomized controlled trial to be
effective and um and so those are kind
of the bigger ones there's other things
that people use like probiotics but
there's a lot of heterogeneity as you
know in probiotics and what to take and
are they really effective vaginally in
the Flora there so those are kind of the
big things and there is is actually a
lot of microbiome study and UTIs going
on actually at UCLA where they're
looking at the microbiome of people who
are more at risk for UTIs or even
overactive blood or other conditions
like that and they're trying to figure
out like is there something here that we
can Target or that we can figure out is
is causing problems because sometimes we
just can't figure out why it's happening
in terms of wiping from front to back
and swimming and peeing after sex
there's no good data on any of those
things wiping from front to back I think
it does create a little bit of like
shame like it's not a big deal if you
wipe back to front as long as you're not
like you know as long as you've like
cleaned yourself so to speak so I think
it's less of an issue what we're talking
about is you're referring to any
contamination from anal any bacteria
around the ants right yeah right and a
lot of women who have recurrent UTIs
like tend to come and feel very dirty
like there's something wrong with them
they're like oh I wash all the time I'm
really clean I'm really this and you
know it's not something they're doing
it's probably a microbiome effect or a
hormonal effect or you know there's
something going on that we need to
investigate further it could also be an
anatomical or functional problem where
you're not emptying the bladder
correctly so there's lots of different
factors it could mean it's like very
infrequent I would say like I've never
seen a patient who's dirty and that's
the reason they're getting UTIs
um perhaps even the opposite is true
they're cleaning too much based on what
you told us earlier yeah and they're
eliminating the gut micro excuse me just
rolls off the tongue um again no pun
intended
um perhaps it's there they are
abolishing the local microbiome on the
skin too much cleaning eliminates the
microbiome on the skin not that we don't
want to wash but when Sonnenberg was a
guest on this podcast he said actually
kids can develop a very healthy
microbiome and general microbiome
oftentimes by sorry parents not washing
their hands before eating if they've
been playing with soil outside or dirt a
little bit of that is actually healthy
pets actually offer microbiome support
this is so weird I know it sounds yeah
but we have to imagine how we evolved as
a species was not with antibacterial
soaps and um alcohol swabs everywhere
and obviously we don't want infections
but over cleaning can disrupt the
microbiome which presumably can lead to
UTI so perhaps someone who's cleaning
excessively is more at risk than
somebody who's cleaning a little less
absolutely and actually the cleaning can
irritate the dermis right so you can
actually get contact dermatitis type
symptoms from over cleaning and so
that's one of the you know things like I
definitely have a UTI I definitely have
one well no you don't but there's a host
of other things that it could be one of
them could be that another very common
one that we already touched on is pelvic
floor dysfunction so very often pelvic
floor dysfunction just like you had pain
with urination women can also develop
pain with urination that doesn't go away
and it can start where they had a UTI
that triggered the pelvic floor and then
the pelvic floor just didn't relax but
the pain just triggered the pelvic floor
to tense up and it didn't relax because
again we're not taught how to relax our
pelvic floor and and then they've done
about pelvic floor dysfunction like why
is UTI not going away why does it keep
coming back and so that's another common
thing that we see in people who have
quote unquote recurrent UTIs but don't
really have them to be clear I
experienced the pain in urination as a
consequence of trying those damn key
goals that everyone's talking about
stopping that
um was informative in two directions one
it relieved the pain very quickly so
that was good the other was I realized
that it is possible to have a pelvic
floor that's neither hyper contracted
nor over relaxed and in some cases just
not doing anything for it is the best
circumstance right so um and the only
reason I mention that is because
um obviously this discussion is not
about my pelvic floor this discussion is
about the fact that some people perhaps
need
to clean less some people maybe more but
probably not based on what you said some
people might need to strengthen their
pelvic floor some people might need to
relax their pelvic floor and some
people's pelvic floor is probably A-Okay
you know any discussion about
um anything medical or you know
especially hormone stuff this happens a
lot in the discussions around
um that I get into it seems with with
males they're like every male now seems
to wonder if their testosterone is too
low except the ones that are blasting
testosterone because they know it's
excessively High
um and as you pointed out earlier
at least in terms of sexual function
that's unlikely to be the case maybe
less desire but
um but in terms of uh genital based
arousal function yeah and I mean you've
talked about testosterone a lot on the
podcast so I'm sure your audience knows
very well the multitude of benefits for
testosterone so I think there is value
in assessing hormones panels and
assessing your level of free
testosterone testosterone and you know
assessing if you're having symptoms that
are not always sexual right it can be
depression it can be weight gain that
you're not gaining muscle mass you can
have cognitive changes so those things
can still be a sign of low testosterone
and very valuable and important to
assess that reminds me of another thing
and then we'll get back to UTIs and I
want to talk about kidney stones but
um I've heard of women using a small
amount of testosterone cream directly on
the clitoris as a way to amplify the
maybe it's the desire and arousal effect
or perhaps just one or the other so I've
uh the way that we discuss testosterone
use and there are like consensus
statements and there's actually an
abundance of data on testosterone use
particularly in post-menopausal women
for low libido or low sexual desire and
it's all been very positive and since
there's been increased uh sexual desire
based on validated questionnaires
increased number of sexually satisfying
events with testosterone use now the
range of testosterone in women is about
a tenth of the the amount of
testosterone a man needs right so
testosterone cream is systemically
absorbed wherever you apply it and so
the way we generally recommend women to
try this if they are having low libido
and we've ruled out other issues that
may be psychologic but you know
relationship other issues that can
affect libido medications there's a lot
of things obviously that go into that
but if we set and we've checked their
testosterone it appears to be low for
physiologic levels for women which again
is one tenth of the male level then we
can actually prescribe off-label
testosterone and the guy guidelines or
the consensus statements they're not
like true guidelines but they recommend
using transdermal testosterone so
getting you know AndroGel tubes from the
pharmacy and putting a tenth of one tube
on the back of the calf or the upper
outer buttock a hairless area for
absorption that can improve desire
overall and then the other place we use
testosterone is in women who have what
we call vestibulodynia so the vestibule
is the area outside the vagina which is
very hormonally active there's lots of
Androgen receptors there and it can
actually when you have hormonal issues
meaning lower testosterone and estrogen
in that area it can cause pain and so
actually applying a combined or
compounded estrogen testosterone cream
to that area over time can reduce that
pain and discomfort so as you know
testosterone receptors or Androgen
receptors all over the body very much in
the genitals very much in the brain and
they're very useful to a very useful
place to treat women for those issues
kidney stones
I hope to never have one I hope you
don't either people get them
um how do you avoid getting them and how
do you get rid of them
so kidney stones very often are they
they can be for a variety of different
metabolic disorders right so it can be
one dehydration is a very common cause
of it so dehydration combined with maybe
a slight metabolic abnormality where
you're creating more calcium or oxalate
in your urine can result in um in kidney
stones and so how can you prevent them I
mean like you know each person is
individual if you get a kidney stone
typically we do what's called a 24-hour
urine analysis plus some blood work to
assess what is the metabolic abnormality
so we can Target that either with diet
or with medication and so the kind of
General recommendations for people who
have kidney stones one is increase your
fluid intake to two to three liters
again the same number I told you before
you want to decrease your oxalate intake
now if you Google oxalate you're going
to find a million things that you eat
that have oxalate in them but the big
ones are spinach and rhubarb we think a
lot of nuts too that are you know people
eating a lot more nuts to get more
protein so you know cutting back it's
impossible to get rid of all of that in
your diet but if you're having like a
spinach salad every day well switch it
to a different green right don't eat
spinach every day
um also you want to increase your
citrate intake that's an inhibitor of
kidney stone formation so increasing
fruits and um and things like that to
increase citrate vegetables as well
actually one easily accessible thing is
Crystal Light it has a high citrate
composition so you can drink Crystal
Light with that two to three liters and
that can be helpful you want to decrease
your protein intake so high levels of uh
purines or perogenic Meats like red
meats and things can also put you at
higher risk so these are kind of the
general sort of preventative measures we
talk about for kidney stones if you have
a kidney stone so a lot of times people
can have kidney stones in their kidneys
they're not creating any problems
they're tiny we can observe them over
time
if they start coming if they start
getting very large or they are starting
to move into the ureters or the tubes
that drain the kidney oftentimes they're
they're accompanied with pain quite a
bit of pain
um and it can be very uncomfortable in
those cases uh we can if they're not
having any infection symptoms I mean
there's no signs of a urinary tract
infection there's no fevers no chills we
can treat it conservatively with pain
medication and also there are
medications like Flomax which you use
for enlarged prostate as well that
actually relaxes the urethral smooth
muscle to allow the stone to pass a
little bit better if you're having an
infection you got to get treated right
away it you can get very sick very
quickly in fact I've seen young healthy
patients like they're healthier than me
walk in the in the ER with a kidney
stone and within 24 hours they're in the
ICU because they're really sick because
of a kidney stone
urinating uh tea colored urine so the
meaning blood in the urine yeah all of
those are important warning signs that
you ideally don't get to yeah blood in
the urine I mean doesn't always mean
infection it could just be from the
stone but certainly fevers chills or you
have a sign of an infection and the
stone looks like it's blocking so if you
get Imaging and you see what's called
hydronephrosis or pressure behind the
kidney and you're you know you have
these signs of infection we don't want
to wait because you can get sick pretty
quickly and then you know once to treat
the kidney stones there's three major
options one is shock waves another is
ureteroscopy where we go in with a
camera and we have a small laser we
break it up into small pieces and
there's the camera inserted through the
urethra correct your sleep under
anesthesia so you don't have to you saw
that yeah I saw you saw the winds
and then perky utifer lozotomy which is
done if you have a large kidney stone or
a very hard kidney stone that's up in
the kidney you can go in through the
back with a small like a small incision
and with a specialized camera that goes
in and uses ultrasonic lithotripsy to
break up that stone and kind of suck it
out that way these are extremely helpful
um bits of information are not even bits
these are this enormous amount of useful
information
I like to Pivot again
um for sake of bread we can't go into
extreme depth on everything but um
appreciate your willingness to to follow
this Carousel with me
um oral contraception
previously on this podcast I hosted a
female physician guest who
offered both sides of female oral
contraception discussed some of the
benefits discuss some of the risks
I made the decision to post clips about
both on the internet and wow wow wow was
I
surprised but also frankly a bit shocked
and then finally
um intrigued by how polarized the
discussion is around female oral
contraception and female contraception
in general
so NuvaRing nor plant the pill
broad category of things there but for
sake of discussion the pill
Etc
I mean it seemed that approximately 50
percent of responses which seem to come
mainly from women
were of the this stuff is terrible it
ruined my life it ruins lives it um
destroys you it has immense
um risk and then the other half
seemed to say no there's reduced risk of
certain forms of cervical cancer
um this has allowed me uh the you know
sexual choices and lifestyle that I
prefer without risk of pregnancy I mean
it was
astonishing to the point where I thought
wow if only I could post both Clips
simultaneously so
um obviously I don't know what the
answer is um but I do know that this is
among the more polarizing topics
available for discussion
um so what is the story meaning what are
the data about oral contraception why so
much controversy and what's the real
deal here yes so it is a very polarizing
topic and there is abundance data
abundant data in fact we even did a
study and again this is
um not like high quality evidence but we
looked at Reddit threads and we looked
at sexual dysfunction specifically low
libido orgasmic difficulties and we like
read hundreds of threads and we did like
a qualitative analysis in females to see
like what are people talking about and
problems with oral contraceptives and
antidepressants leading to low libido
and and being very like as you describe
very like this has ruined my life was
very common and so the theory is that
you know taking oral contraceptives
increases the amount of sex hormone
binding globulin which binds
testosterone and estrogen and that
actually makes testosterone less
available which is as we've talked about
a very important hormone for desire and
so in some subset of people they're
seeing very significant consequences of
taking oral contraceptives now I think
that there is you know we don't know
which women are going to have this
problem and we don't know how it's
probably a very small subset of people
but we do know that this does happen and
that when you measure shpg levels
they're up and that even after they stop
the oral contraceptives you'll see
elevated shbg levels from Baseline for
how long you know for like at least four
months afterwards you'll still see
elevated shpg levels so we don't know
but not infinite
we don't know we don't know yeah the
endocrine system is weird because it it
um we assume everything is a short-term
effect but there's some plasticity in
the system especially because it's a
neuroendocrine system so yeah okay so I
think yeah there's some neuroplasticity
there that occurs as well and so uh we
do see this and I think that the other
side of it is yeah absolutely oral
contraceptives are amazing right they're
they're helpful for sexual Freedom so
for for preventing pregnancy for you
know for a lot of things and
particularly other conditions too like
PCOS and and other problems oral
contraceptives are amazing and they've
changed uh you know Gynecology and
management of these women for you know
in in a very positive way and so I think
you know yes I do think that there is
oral contraceptive related sexual
dysfunction usually low-dose estrogen
sort of contraceptives are the culprit
uh but you know I think that it's it's
again the data female sexual respect
literature is just not as robust as male
sexual dysfunction literature I saw a
lot of comments about how oral
contraception had led to depressive-like
symptoms
um or just kind of a hedonia and apathy
not just lower libido I can imagine how
that would be the case through the
elevated sex hormone binding globulin
which is you know preventing
testosterone estrogen from
um being free right literally and
exerting their effects on not just the
body but the brain but is there any
evidence that oral contraception can
disrupt no transmitters I'm not aware of
any I don't think
knowledge
uh well it sounds to me like
oral contraception
for women because that's where we
normally hear about it it sounds like
there's a varied response and it's
highly individual I certainly had
partners that love the pill or at least
didn't seem to mind it I've had some
that hated it and like it's like no way
tried that never will
um or you know just went with other
forms of contraception or for whatever
reason we're not using contraception so
it seems to me that
there's a lot of variation out there how
does one explore that without risk of
permanent damage it sounds like truly
permanent damage is unlikely
um
you know what are the other options you
know is the ring
um uh copper IUD
um so any sort of long-acting hormonal
contraceptive we've seen we've we that's
what we counsel patients on is if
they're having issues with oral
contraceptives even if they come in with
pelvic pain and they're on oral
contraceptives I'll tell them you know
what just stop because maybe the engine
the effect of on the Androgen receptors
or estrogen receptors is affecting you
know the lubrication or other things
we're not sure but you know why don't
you stop it and go get a long-acting
contraceptive method like an IUD like an
IUD and our IUD is our IUD safe and here
we should probably say Okay copper IUD
is one form you want to mention a few of
the other forms so I don't prescribe
iuds but generally speaking they're very
safe of course there's risk with any
sort of you know it's a procedure you're
inserting an IUD so there's obviously
some small risks associated with it but
it is safe and effective form of
contraception people are wondering why
the copper IUD is an effective form of
contraception copper is like the third
rail for sperm as I understand it so
much so that um I was able to find some
evidence for this in the medical
textbooks that
um in the old days as I say
um prostitutes who wanted to avoid
pregnancy would put copper pennies in
their vagina really oh now I don't
recommend that to anyone and uh please
and um I don't think it's a foolproof
form of of uh contraception but there is
evidence that that um did happen so
which is amazing that means that people
somehow figured out the copper sperm
relationship which isn't a good one for
the sperm and deduced from that of
behavior yeah that's
I think it's just an interesting medical
factoid yeah
I can tell you want to move on from this
topic so we will
um before discussing prostate and anal
sex
not
stated next to one another for any
particular reason I want to talk about
ssris a lot of people over the last 20
30 years have been prescribed selective
serotonin reuptake Inhibitors and other
antidepressants
that have disrupted their sexual
function or their sexual desire it seems
in particular
um
do you see a lot of this in your clinic
do you hear about it what can people do
about it
um you know oftentimes these sexual uh
arousal or dysfunction issues associated
with ssris and other medications make
those medications prohibitive for people
so you know serotonin is kind of the
anti-2 orgasm and so in fact we will use
ssris off label for people who are
having premature ejaculation so it
delays ejaculation and then there's also
other sexual dysfunctions we see with it
and it does happen absolutely it's dose
dependent so in some cases when someone
comes in with SSRI related dysfunction
if they're doing well you can either try
to reduce the dose or switch them to
another antidepressant for example
Wellbutrin that does not have such
severe effects on sexual function
um and so you can also use like Cialis
and Viagra like you've taught well we've
talked about for erectile dysfunction as
an addition if we can't change their
medication management because you know
and it gets a little bit complicated
because we know erectile dysfunction and
depression are very interrelated now
what's causing what and what you know
where do we like maybe somebody went to
see their doctor for depression was also
having issue with erections and now what
do you if you fix the erections do you
help with the depression like what you
know what I mean so it goes everywhere
are shouting yes so I think you know I
think that there's a lot of discussion
has to be had there it's a lot easier to
talk to your primary care doctor about
depression than it is about your
erections and so I think it's important
to like really dig into that a little
bit but yes there it is definitely a
known thing we use it to our advantage
when needed and um and it can be helpful
to to switch medications or reduce the
dose
you mentioned earlier that trazodone can
cause um sustained erection
um and is trazodone in the category of
of touching the serotonin transmission
system you know I don't remember the
mechanism but interestingly trazodone is
also used for off label like as a third
or fourth line for premature ejaculation
as well so um so I I don't remember the
the mechanism offhand
let's talk about
prostate
and prostate health earlier I queued up
that um there's a growing Trend toward I
would say more Progressive male
Physicians or Physicians who treat males
excuse me
um thanks for that yeah
um prescribing low dose 2.5 to 5
milligram Cialis which is to Dallas
which may assist with erections but it
the the rationale for this low-dose
daily low dose is not centered around
erections per se it's really about
um prostate health improving blood flow
to the prostate reducing prostatitis
um maybe even reducing the probability
of prostate cancer
um what other sorts of things are you
encouraging men to think about when
thinking about their prostate yes so
before I forget I want to mention that
low dose tadalafel is actually a
treatment for erectile dysfunction in
fact it works quite well particularly
men who are having a lot of psychogenic
issues one because they don't have to
remember to take a pill before sex it's
always on board and you know you're
taking five milligrams every day and it
has a 36 hour Half-Life so over you know
you're kind of increasing those so it
can actually work quite well and is a
great option for erectile dysfunction so
I do want to make that caveat in terms
of prostate health it has been shown to
be effective for BPH or enlarged
prostate this is a very common condition
in fact if you look at autopsy studies
eighty percent of men at 80 have an
enlarged prostate like it's very very
common now does everyone get symptoms
and what's the long-term concerns of it
and you know what can you do about it so
typically as the prostate enlarges it's
right around the urethra it's a
walnut-shaped gland sits underneath the
bladder around the urethra and it can
narrow the urethra or the P tube and so
over time you can imagine like if you're
I always give this example if you're
sucking from a straw right you're
drinking from a straw if you have a wide
diameter straw it's really easy to drink
if your straw gets really narrow like
say you take a coffee straw and you
drink out of that it's very difficult to
drink very similarly it can become very
difficult to urinate if you have an
enlarged prostate now what causes an
enlarged prostate there's a whole host
of factors a lot of them are genetic so
if your father or grandfather had a
large prostate you're probably more
likely to have an enlarged prostate
do we know exactly how to prevent that
not exactly but we know how to mediate
the symptoms a little bit so the other
symptoms you'll see before you have
difficulty urinating is sometimes you'll
see overactivity so you'll see your
bladder is responding to having to push
hard against that narrow your re-thread
to push urine out so it's having more
urgency like the sudden desire to go to
the bathroom that you can't delay you're
maybe going more frequently and very
often you're going more often at night
and so those are kind of the first signs
people will see and then over time it
may become more and more difficult to
empty the bladder you might see some
hesitancy like you're waiting for your
stream to start or it stops and starts
um and so those you know or you're just
like I can't empty like it's not because
just drips or a very weak stream and so
those are kind of the things that can
happen over a lifetime now what what are
some things that you can do to help
um you know Cialis helps relax those
those the fiber the smooth muscle of the
prostate so that it allows urine to pass
more easily there's also other
medications that you can treat very
often Flomax or other alpha blockers are
helpful in that area in terms of like
things that you can do in general for
bladder health prostate health there's
certain things that are irritants to
that area and so what I tell people not
everyone's affected the same way so I
don't want people to be like oh I gotta
stop all these delicious things I eat
and drink but certainly it can be useful
to just pay attention so like if you say
you drink coffee every day and you find
yourself right in the bathroom a lot if
you limit your caffeine intake you might
see that you're not going to the
bathroom quite as often because caffeine
is a bladder irritant so that can be
coffee tea chocolate you know things of
that nature that have caffeine in them
energy drinks sometimes people forget
they have caffeine in them and so
limiting that may improve your symptoms
alcohol also is a bladder irritant and
these have actually been studied in
animal models and you'll see that the
bladder contracts more often when
they're given these sorts of substances
and it's dose dependent and some people
can actually habituate or get used to a
certain dose of caffeine so if you're
drinking coffee every day you may have
less symptoms than someone who drinks it
every once in a while
other things can be sometimes carbonated
beverages spicy foods or acidic Foods
those sorts of things can also irritate
the bladder lining so sometimes limiting
those things may be helpful in those
situations
very informative
um years ago there was a discussion
about
um
bicycle seats causing damage to the
prostate maybe even sexual dysfunction
um is that still a thing I thought they
put grooves into the the seats
um but I've also in reading on the
internet I didn't do a deep dive on
Reddit but um seems that women are
reporting some Bladder incontinence from
excessive bicycle seat use maybe even
um exercise bike doesn't have to be road
bike yeah so this is a great point so
cycling if you think about it right
you're sitting on your perineum which is
that space for men between the scrotum
and the anus for women between the
vagina and the anus and right there runs
your pudendal artery and your pudendal
nerve which are again responsible for
blood flow and nerve function to the
area so the most common things we see in
people who are you know who are really
high volume cyclers now the studies have
looked at like maybe they did a 350
kilometer race or they they're you know
biking three times a week for 60 minutes
but there's no like consistency but
there's seeing pretty high rates of
genital numbness so like up to 50
percent and also in men erectile
dysfunction in women you'll also see
numbness but because sensation is a big
part of arousal you'll also see kind of
decreased lubrication maybe decreased
arousal as well in women and so how can
you prevent that the reason is because
when you're sitting particularly if
you're leaning forward like competitive
bikers who are Arrow riding you're
putting pressure on the the beak of the
bicycle seat and that's where you know
most of the it's not your weight it's
not distributed evenly so the goal is to
take a bike seat that allows you to sit
comfortably on your ischial tuberosities
and posture is a huge part of your
pelvic floor I know we didn't talk about
that earlier but sitting you know with
good posture and not kind of slouching
or leaning forward can actually really
do wonders for your pelvic floor so
focusing on posture is helpful but also
when biking posture is helpful so
they've actually looked at this data and
they found that people who Arrow ride
meaning Lean Forward
are people who use narrow bike seats are
more likely to have issues and so you
want to get kind of a noseless seat and
a wider seat the the cutouts actually
when they've looked at kind of mechanics
of the cutouts they'll see higher
pressure around the opening so it's
actually not good to have a a bike with
a cutout a bike seat with a cutout
because they've seen at least with some
of the cutouts the pressure actually
becomes higher on the area that's right
around it
very important Point
um I don't cycle I don't like the
exercise bike I'll sometimes Ride The
Assault bike for which has the big seat
maybe for a few minutes but um I just
want to add one one thing because I
think that I don't want to uh make
people not cycle I think it's really
valuable cycling is a great aerobic
exercise has lots of benefit for
cardiovascular health but there was
actually another study that looked at
people who were parts of sports club so
they were like swimmers Runners and and
cyclists and they looked at rates of
dysfunction and they found that actually
the rate of erectile dysfunction was not
different between Runners swimmers and
cyclers so maybe you know because those
other sites were just looking at cyclers
that maybe it's just the general rate of
erectile dysfunction in that population
at that point in time so I don't the
numbness is definitely an issue the
erectile dysfunction maybe maybe not
so I just have a couple of more
questions for you and by the way you've
been incredibly generous with your time
and information here thank you so I
really appreciate it as I'm sure our
listeners do as well
anal sex
you recently did a post describing the
multiple reasons why women do or do not
have anal sex yes very interesting post
very interesting study that you covered
yeah and you um explained it very
clearly
um I'm guessing there are
relatively few but perhaps some other
studies as well about this
um let's talk about anal sex and uh
maybe if you could just offer some of
the the key bullet points that you've
learned from the literature and from
your clinical practice
um you know how frequent is it
um uh with protection without protection
how safe is it
um
you know what are the different reasons
people do it that might seem like a kind
of a silly question but it turns out
when it comes to this topic it's there
are interesting data yeah yeah
um educate us so anal sex let's talk
about it um well when you when you talk
about anal sex the reason people it's
become more and more common let's say
it's more and more heterosexual couples
are doing it we know that male
homosexual couples are having anal sex
and I think the one thing is that it's
safe in terms of pregnancy right you're
not going to get pregnant from anal sex
which is one of the reasons people do
engage in anal sex do you think that's
the reason people are doing it more
frequently no I think that's one of the
reasons that people one of the reasons
but in general the issue with anal sex
is that people forget to use protection
like a condom for example because
sexually transmitted infections are
actually more likely with anal sex than
they are with vaginal penetrative
intercourse because the anal tissue is
very thin and friable so when you
penetrate the anus particularly if you
have any trauma you can have you know
you can have blood loss and that blood
loss can then easily more easily
transmit sexually to the infection so
it's really important to use a condom
and use adequate lubrication the anus
does not make any of its endogenous
lubrication you have to use lubricant
the other interesting thing about anal
sex is that the anus pH is different
from the vaginal pH so you want to use
specific lubricants that are ISO osmolar
to anal pH so you can actually look up
anal lubricants and we could talk about
lubricants but generally there is
water-based silicone-based oil-based
lubricants water-based are the most
easily accessible
silicone based are a little more
slippery and lasts a little longer and
oil based also last longer but are not
good freeze with condoms so definitely
using lubricants and always kind of
making sure to be in the context of
course of being consensual but also like
never for course always take your time
and those things are really important to
avoid trauma because trauma can happen
and usually it's not severe trauma right
it's not going to create long lasting
problems but it is you know inconvenient
uncomfortable and probably we're not
seeing as much of it because they're not
coming to the emergency room if they're
having issues unless it's really serious
so I think it's really important one to
prevent from a sexually transmitted
infections to to be thoughtful and
cautious and sometimes it requires some
preparation if you're going to penetrate
an anus it's gonna you know you're not
gonna start with a a large girth item
you're going to start with something
smaller and kind of work your way up
um and then I think ultimately why
people have anal sex so as I mentioned
earlier the prostate is you know highly
innervated and can be a source of
pleasure so some people enjoy that
particularly men may enjoy anal
penetration women as well may enjoy anal
penetration because of the innervation
around there the pelvic floor
um and and you know so that's certainly
reasonable to do so as far as why people
engage in anal sex so sometimes it's
because as I mentioned they're trying to
avoid vaginal penetration either to
avoid pregnancy or maybe
menstruation or other reasons sometimes
it's because people want to do something
special with their partner like they
feel like this is my special thing with
this partner that I do with them and so
it may be something kind of like a gift
or something like that sometimes it's
almost like they feel like they um they
have to and this particular story that I
looked at there's actually not a lot of
studies on why people engage in anal sex
and this particular study that I had
talked about on my channel or my
Instagram was talking about why they've
specifically recruit drug users and so a
lot of people had used drugs prior to
using to engaging in anal sex and I
think that that's not ideal you always
want to be kind of in the right State of
Mind for consent and
um and safety purposes and so um those
were kind of the common reasons what
about infection not related to sexually
transmitted infection
um my presumption is there is a higher
risk with anal sex than there is with
other
um other you know vaginal intercourse
oral sex Etc
um but is there evidence for that
um not necessarily it's more about
sexually transmitted infections
it's rare you can sometimes I mean the
rare things that people have kind of
commented on like anal incontinence
temporarily or things like that very
rare
um mostly it's it's just sexually
transmitted infections because you know
you can't have more it's more easy to
create bleeding through anal sex if
you're not careful and are people doing
enemas before anal sex to prevent
bacterial infection or is that just like
it's a kind of some people are
I think it's you know
you know for their evacuated fully
there's some you know media articles
about like what you should eat before to
kind of keep your gut you know healthy
and avoid kind of loose stools and
things like that but generally speaking
you know there's there's lots of things
you can look up to make it safe and
healthy
again I'm sure some people are listening
to this and they're maybe they've turned
it off already but
um and I think we can expect a varied
response to this discussion but it's
happening out there
apparently with an increasing frequency
yes and I don't know if that's because
of the increasing availability of
pornography where it's visualized more
or if
um I don't really know why but we do
know that there's more going on in
heterosexual couples than prior as a
final category of question
um I was really interested in some of
the posts you've done about
herbs and supplements in the context of
sexual desire and sexual function
um on this podcast I always say always
always we emphasize behavioral tools
first do's and don'ts right because
those are the foundation of mental
health physical health and performance
you know in all contexts
um there is of course a role for
prescription drugs sometimes oftentimes
people can't do the things and avoid the
certain things they want to because of
depressive States anxious States Etc and
prescription drugs can serve a role but
I do believe the goal is always
um behaviors first then of course things
like adequate sleep nutrition healthy
social interaction all of that stuff
right exercise
but we do often talk about supplements
um because they represent
um I think an important category of you
know over-the-counter compounds that can
play a role and um I've talked before
about Tonga Ali this Indonesian herb I
think it can be Malaysian as well but
this Indonesian um herb is typically the
one that um I'm aware works best for
mild libido enhancement sometimes
especially in the case of people taking
ssris
um it can enhance libido to override
some of the uh challenges with SSRI
induced reduction in libido and
generally even if people aren't under
ssris I hear from people who take Tonga
Ali and get libido increases also things
like maca root which we
don't really know how these things work
exactly probably some freeing up of
testosterone with Tongan Ali maybe some
cortisol suppression as well maybe some
estrogen receptor modulation with maca
root maybe some dopaminergic tone
changes
um Sheila G
um this ayurvedic herb um which there is
at least one study
um that uh I think has done well that
shows increases in FSH follicle
stimulating hormone with um Sheila G use
what are your thoughts on things like
Tonga Ali maca root shilaji
um how do you talk to your patients
about this stuff yeah so I think that
you know I see at least my patient
population is is still in the Behavioral
Management place right the biggest cause
of sexual dysfunction whether it's low
testosterone erectile dysfunction sexual
dysfunction is often comorbidities right
so managing high blood pressure managing
diabetes with diet which you talk about
a lot but the best studied diet is the
Mediterranean diet at least in in a
sexual dysfunction literature exercise
like doing you know both cardiovascular
aerobic exercise but also doing
resistance training particularly like
large muscle groups
um and and then uh you know really
working on reducing blood pressure and
and preventing diabetes and those things
I think are really key and I know we
talk you talk about them a lot on this
podcast but I will tell you that when
people are getting ready for for example
we do a surgery for erectile dysfunction
called penile prosthesis so this is like
end of the line nothing's working they
can't get an erection at all and it can
be a and they may have diabetes as a
cause of it when we say you know you
have to get your hemoglobin A1c below a
certain level to do surgery I cannot
tell you how quickly these men change
their behaviors for sake of erection for
sake of erections so I think that really
if I can say one thing before you do uh
supplements which I don't have a problem
with I think that it's reasonable to try
them
um I would try one at a time to see
what's working and so you're not taking
a bunch of things and not knowing what
exactly is working and realizing that
they're not going to work immediately if
you take something that works
immediately it's probably got a pde5
inhibitor mixed in there and so it's
going to kind of build over time and
you're going to see changes over time
but I would say that the number one
thing that I recommend for people is
improving their diet exercising getting
good sleep as you know it boosts
testosterone and even you know you
mention this all the time but getting
early morning light but it's it's
beneficial for testosterone as well
because you're really helping release
testosterone with a circadian biology G
so I think that those things like I
can't stress enough like how valuable
they are and if you're smoking quit
smoking it will kill your erection and
vaping and vaping yeah and then lastly
if you are developing true organic
impotence meaning that there's a
biologic problem that's causing your
sexual dysfunction then it's really
important to get your cardiovascular
health assessed because about 15 of men
who develop erectile dysfunction seven
years later will have a cardiovascular
event it is the canary in the coal mine
meaning that you know it's a sign that
you may be developing cardiovascular
problems or like endothelial dysfunction
that's first presenting in the penis or
in their sexual organs and you know this
probably is the same for women we just
don't have the data yet
I know a good number of women that take
Tonga Ali in part I think on the
recommendation although I want to be
clear I never recommended it it was an
offer of something that people could try
if they're doing everything else
correctly and could assess
um with Consulting your physician of
course
um and they too some of them have uh
reported improvements in libido and
desires as well so yeah um yeah and I
the Sheila G is less known about the um
distinguishing quality versus low
quality sources of shilaji is harder
dosing is harder it comes as this tar
typically typically
um maybe more science on Trilogy will
come out in the next few years we could
um get get behind it a bit more right
now I'm sort of on the yeah maybe if you
are an adventurer you might try it but
I'm not um it's not one that I'd
normally throw to the top of the list
yeah I think that like l-citrulline is
is pretty good ashwagandha for stress
reduction which also has implications
for sexual function tongue cataly has
reasonable data
um I think there you know there is
reasonable data on these things I think
the webs that you talk about all the
time examine.com is a great place to
look at that
um and you know like I said I think it's
reasonable they're smaller studies
they're not
um you know there is bias in many
studies but they're they're you know
there is effort done in this area and
there's never going to be really high
quality science no one's going to really
fund that I think
um so I think our expectations need to
be a little tempered when it comes to
that stuff
Rena
Dr Malik I want to thank you ever so
much for this discussion today you
provide us so much useful information
um and really have transcended the
Divide between you know the mysterious
thing that everyone wants to know about
sex and Sexual Health genitals and
genital Health uh prostate urethra UTIs
all these topics that
um many people are just afraid to to
raise and and to confront directly and
you've um you've taught us so much about
how to promote the health of this
incredibly important system absolutely
one thing we know for sure either in
Vivo or in a dish we're all here because
a sperm had an egg and uh and um and of
course there are other reasons why
people engage in sexual activity that
have nothing to do with reproduction but
um surely it is our biology and our
psychology and well-being so thank you
so much and also thank you for the work
you do day in and day out week in and
week out in your clinic
we'll provide links to your clinic
people are interested in working with
you directly as well as online that's
how I initially found you and when I did
I was just absolutely delighted I
thought finally there's somebody who's
providing the kind of information that
everybody wants in a in a thoughtful
logical clear and respectful way so on
behalf of all the listeners and viewers
and on behalf of myself I just want to
say thank you thank you thank you for
what you do and please keep going and
please come back thank you so much and
honestly the work you do is phenomenal
it's an honor to be here thank you so
much
thank you for joining me for today's
discussion with Dr Rena Malik all about
Urology pelvic floor and Sexual Health
if you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a
five-star review if you have questions
for me or comments about the podcast or
guests that you'd like me to consider
hosting on the huberman Lab podcast
please put those in the comment section
on YouTube I do read all the comments
please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast not on
today's podcast but on many previous
episodes of The huberman Lab podcast we
discuss supplements while supplements
aren't necessary for everybody many
people derive tremendous benefit from
them for things like improving sleep
hormone support and focus the huberman
Lab podcast has partnered with momentous
supplements if you'd like to access the
supplements discussed on the huberman
Lab podcast you can go to live momentous
spelled ous so it's livemomentis.com
huberman and you can also receive twenty
percent off again that's live momentous
spelled ous.com slash huberman if you
haven't already subscribed to our neural
network newsletter our neural network
newsletter is a completely zero cost
monthly newsletter that includes
summaries of podcast episodes as well as
protocols that is short PDFs describing
for instance tools to improve sleep
tools to improve neuroplasticity we talk
about deliberate cold exposure Fitness
various aspects of mental health again
all completely zero cost and to sign up
you simply go to hubermanlab.com go over
to the menu in the corner scroll down to
newsletter and provide your email we do
not share your email with anybody if
you're not already following me on
social media I am huberman lab on all
platforms so that's Instagram Twitter
threads LinkedIn and Facebook and at all
of those places I talk about science and
science related tools some of which
overlaps with the content of the
huberman Lab podcast but much of which
is distinct from the content of the
huberman Lab podcast again it's lab on
all social media platforms thank you
once again for joining me for today's
discussion with Dr Rena Malik and last
but certainly not least thank you for
your interest in science
[Music]